facebook's
fake oversight board whatever that is
supposed to be
a group of a bunch of leftists who are
supposedly
giving facebook oversight have done not
that and said donald trump should stay
banned but
you know how about you decide mark
zuckerberg because it's a big fat waste
of time
and we knew that was going to be the
case they'd give us nothing definitive
trump is banned the sitting president
was banned he can't come back
he's probably he literally is the most
pro uh prominent candidate
for 2024 assuming he allows he's running
yet still he will be banned because you
know we live in an oligopoly
and the republicans just come out and go
oh geez oh man oh i can't believe this
is happening i'm so surprised you know
we're going to fight tooth and nail
because they didn't when they could
they're certainly not going to do it now
but now it's really easy because they
can pretend like they can or they're
going to
even though they can't because they have
no power in government right now so
seems like a big fat waste of time but
interestingly black lives matters
black lives matter has a new list of
demands one of which is that trump must
be banned
i have no idea what that has to do with
saving lives
i guess it may be black lives matter is
it's a political organization that is
helping the democrats so
we'll talk all about that i suppose but
we've got uh probably one of the
foremost experts on big tech censorship
alan bakari is joining us
how's it going man you want to introduce
how's it going i'm alan bakari i'm the
senior tech correspondent for breitbart
news
i've been covering tech since 2015 when
no one could imagine that a president
might be censored on social media
uh when the left loved technology
because uh
facebook allegedly elected barack obama
and i also wrote the book
uh deleted big text battle to erase the
trump movement and steal
the election you can follow me on
twitter at libertarianblue
that's an old twitter handle which i
can't change i'm not really libertarian
there you go ian's john you used to be a
libertarian 2015 everyone was a
libertarian you know the
ron pa the ron paul age before donald
trump the only guy
who was worth supporting was ron paul
what's up everybody in crossland in the
house in awesome.net thanks for coming
yeah and i'm in the corner as well
pushing buttons for this cool show
we got a bunch of crazy stuff because we
were talking about just before the show
you mentioned the florida bill on
anti-censorship was actually garbage it
i wouldn't go as far as saying it was
garbage but it could have gone a lot
further than it did
right on so we'll get in all that
there's a lot to talk about before we
get started head over to timcast.com
click that big old beautiful members
only button sign up and then go to the
members area where you can see a whole
bunch of amazing
members only exclusive segments we were
talking with kimberly klasik the other
day
should black lives matter was a
communist organization most mostly a
response to
what many chinese donors were saying
they were giving money to the proud boys
because they fear that black lives
matter is trying to stage a communist
revolution in the united states
and so we talked to kimberly klasik
about it and she may she she spoke a lot
about how the democratic policies have
been
just a disaster for black family so go
to timcast.com sign up if you want to
see segments like that we also talk
about gina carano
we got jack murphy we got drew hernandez
a lot of really great uh conversations
and don't forget to like share subscribe
hit that notification bell and share the
show with your friends if you really
like it
leave us five stars on itunes spotify
and good reviews let's get into that
first
story we got cnn uh good old trusty cnn
facebook tried to punt the trump
decision that backfired it's an
interesting take
they say the facebook oversight board
was designed to make some of facebook's
most difficult
decisions for the company but on
wednesday the board put one of the
biggest dilemmas facing the platform
back on facebook and company ceo mark
zuckerberg
the board said facebook was right to
suspend trump in the immediate aftermath
of the insurrection but facebook
couldn't just
make the suspension indefinite with no
actual rule on its book
so basically everybody was waiting for
this huge
moment was this supposedly independent
body going to say
donald trump should be allowed back on
instead they were like well i mean
mark mark you decide so there's no real
point having them we knew this was going
to be the case
we know that let me just slow down
is anyone really surprised i'm i'm
surprised people are like
well this is crazy a sitting president
was banned yeah it was banned four
months ago what are you talking about
how is this news
yeah i mean did anyone really expect
this facebook oversight board staffed
entirely by anti-trump figures
uh people who compared trump to hitler
in one case was ever going to come to
any other conclusion of course they're
going to uphold the ban and what they've
done is they've essentially passed the
buck back to facebook saying you know
well in six months you have to make a
final decision it's in your court now
so uh facebook already made their final
decision yeah the oversight board was
supposed to be this special thing but
i'm
i just love how how stupid so many
people are
when they were like first of all the
journalists who are like oh no
oh what do what if what if they
overturned trump's ban oh jeez
but then you have these these gop guys
these these these uh congressmen and
women
who are like i can't believe they made
this decision uh we gotta break up these
companies
it's it's all meaningless it's a big
meaningless waste of our time yeah
what's the gop going to do at the
national level they don't hold power
when they did held power they didn't do
any do much about it
i will say the trump administration was
on the verge of doing something about it
in the final year but the final year was
too late
they should have acted uh 2017 2018 when
people started getting banned from these
these platforms uh the only hope on a
political level now is that uh at the
state level
and you know texas has an interesting
bill florida has a
could be worse bill i guess uh but
better than nothing
it's better than nothing it does impose
some transparency requirements on the
tech companies which unlike the rest of
the bill can actually be enforced
uh but the texas bill actually is very
interesting and uh senate bill 12 in
texas that's worth taking a look at
what is that going to do so unlike the
the florida bill the texas bill has a
general provision against viewpoint
based censorship
that doesn't mention the word common
carry or public accommodation
which are the two laws you can use to
regulate businesses and you know
restrict who they can and cannot deny
service to uh but it functions in much
the same way
and the reason why that's important is
because unless
there are only like uh a few legal
routes and you know i'll profess it by
saying i'm a lawyer but there's only a
few legal routes you can go
to set to tell a business who they can
and cannot deny service to
or whose speech they can and cannot host
because otherwise they'll just say well
we're businesses businesses are
considered persons by uh by us law
therefore we have first amendment rights
to
to host the viewpoint we wanted to
censor the viewpoints we want
but there are certain types of
businesses that can't do that
uh common carriers have to provide
access to everyone on a
reasonable non-discriminatory basis uh
public accommodations have to do the
same under civil rights law there are
also state laws like california's unreal
law which is very wide-ranging and has
actually been used
uh in in viewpoint discrimination cases
successfully to say no
businesses can't exclude people like
even small businesses kind of the
unrollers
the unreal law that's the california law
right i remember uh talking about that
but
can you break it down for us uh so it's
like a wide arranging uh version of like
the civil rights law you can't
discriminate based on like a wide range
of categories
and courts in california have
interpreted that to extend to viewpoint
so um really businesses that trying to
exclude like political extremists
from uh their uh their property uh have
been shot down in the courts the courts
have said that you can't do that
uh under the california constitution as
well uh there was a very famous case in
the 1980s and this is an honorable this
is
this is their constitution but there was
a famous case in the 80s
uh called pruniard v robbins and that
was a shopping mall
that was taken to court because it
didn't allow political activism uh
on their property and the court said
well under california law under the
california constitution shopping malls
have to allow political activism
on their property so if california can
do all those things there's no reason
why
texas can't do it florida can't do it
any red state can't do it to the tech
companies
can you just sue based on california law
then to get your account reinstated or
what
well this is the thing uh you know this
has been tried before
the problem that all these state laws
will run into is
the well first of all that didn't apply
to tech companies you'd have to write it
and specifically apply to tech companies
uh the other problem of course is
section 230 of the communications
decency act
uh which is the law that says tech
companies can censor a wide range of
content
that they're not liable for user speech
and that only applies to tech companies
it doesn't apply to shopping malls
man talk about one of the stupidest
things
you know i i can't blame i can't blame
uh
the government the the apology at the
time necessarily because they had no
idea what they were dealing with and
and to a certain degree it made sense
but a lot of people don't realize
i hear this all the time when people are
like they're a publisher now they're a
publisher it's like no that's not what
the law means not how it works
like the new york times you can't sue
them for the comments but there are a
bunch of really
important points to be made like when
twitter publishes those little blurbs
and news
things yeah that is twitter speech
that's twitter making a statement
everyone's a publisher
if you have a website even twitter but
it doesn't
it's it's actionable when twitter says
something not when one of their users
says something
uh yeah well what blows my mind i've
said this before is that wikipedia
enjoys the protection of section 230. i
mean that
makes no sense to me wikipedia says it's
an interactive computer service just
like facebook and twitter and you know
it provides a forum for all these
anonymous editors to make these articles
but the function of wikipedia is clearly
a traditional publisher it brands itself
as an encyclopedia
and it says on every article from
wikipedia not from you know joe bob jr
precisely and you know if the
encyclopedia britannica published you
know
in its paper encyclopedia far less
influential to wikipedia these days if
they defamed someone they'd be held
liable for that
but wikipedia defames people all the
time it's the entire purpose of some of
these articles about conservative
figures
and yeah you conservatives can't sue
them over that why can't
you mess with tried uh people have tried
yes in various uh jurisdictions but uh
have they ever made that argument that
wikipedia is not
look it's it's it's we've talked about
this before we had larry sanger on who
was one of the co-founders
and we talked about how on twitter it
says you know at
libertarian blue it's you it's your
account your words wikipedia says from
wikipedia
if you want to see what the user's
posting you got to go to the you got to
go to the uh
the um what's it called the history you
got it you got history yeah
view the history of the article and then
you can see post made by this person
the article itself is not is an article
published by wikipedia period
uh yeah but somehow section 230 protects
and it just shows how broken the law is
that it's protecting
the most one of the most powerful
publishers out there the site that's at
the top of nearly every
google search that can defame almost
anyone maybe the issue is
people haven't sued properly and the
argument needs to be
show the judge a picture of the article
where it says from wikipedia and say
so long as we keep here wikipedia
purports that the words on this page
that show no reference to any users or
any uh individuals
it says all of this is from wikipedia
then wikipedia has asserted it it has
published this of its own volition
i mean i i would like to see people try
i'm not a lawyer but i
i assume like the amount of people that
wikipedia has defamed
i'm amazed that uh if there was a
possibility even the slightest
possibility you could win a defamation
case against them i'm sure someone would
have tried it by now
but i could be wrong i hope to be proven
wrong on that point i guess the issue is
damages
yeah you know for uh proving damages is
always particularly hard
but the main issue is that you need
millions of dollars to do it
i've heard so many stories from
prominent conservatives where they've
been defamed
a million a million one ways and it's
like well i don't have any money so i
can't sue them
that's all that's it massive
corporations can get away with it
individuals can't really do much about
it that's why social media was so
powerful because it finally gave the
individuals a chance to speak up and
push back
well now that's being threatened if you
got the wrong opinions
you're gone yeah if the uh the momentum
of the alternative media and independent
journalism that existed in 2015 and 2016
had been allowed to continue who didn't
have the rise of censorship would have
totally eclipsed cnn and the new york
times and watched washington post that's
why they had to kill it
kill uh kill you know online freedom
right in your speech
i think people need to realize i need
you i think people need to stop
and take a look at some web archives
look at what the internet was 15 years
ago
compare to what it is now look at
youtube 10 years ago compared to what it
is now
and you're gonna go wow i did not
realize how much it changed
before google bought youtube no no no i
mean
yes but i'm just saying say anything but
it was pretty close
i'm just saying the internet in general
has become disney you know what i mean
like
back in the day the internet was nuts
disney's become crazy
the iron lore of oligarchy eventually
eventually ruling elites
inevitably emerged from any uh any
system
yeah well the issue i suppose is
it's a tendency within any system i
suppose
for uh organization
right so you look at movies we used to
make crazy movies a lot of them would
flop some would succeed he ended up with
weird things like groundhog day
amazing movie i don't think it made
blockbuster money
what happens is over time people start
realizing you know makes money giant
robots
blowing up buildings and you know cars
exploding so you get a bunch of
transformers movies with very little
story effect
if any because it transcends culture so
big explosions can be sold all over the
world
but american culture with with you know
english-speaking speakers it's harder to
sell in foreign countries you got to do
a bunch of work
so they're like just making a bunch of
explosions little dialogue and then what
ends up happening is we get all movies
that are just derivative
remakes bland yeah lowest common
denominator stuff
the fifth six seven spider-man remake
okay enough already
yeah yeah yeah and now we're at uh the
same place in the same same way in the
internet
you know for a long time people just
made whatever they want on the internet
it was a really weird place where people
did weird things and then big companies
started to realize what really made
money
they started to invest in only certain
things then big companies didn't like
the idea of french weirdos started
banning them
and now look at the kind of shows that
are available to you
on on youtube what man people people
you really need to think about this only
a few years ago you could go on youtube
and search for the most ridiculous thing
like you know dmt for instance now you
do and it's all like cnn cbs nbc
it's all just big mainstream
corporations it's like turn on tv
yeah we leaked the uh we leaked the
youtube blacklist on this at breitbart
back in 2018.
they have a literal list at youtube that
they call the controversial query
blacklist
and it's just a bunch of political terms
and whenever they add a term to that
black list
has thousands of entries by the way
whenever they add a term
it just reorders the search results so
cnn bbc and you know whatever
everything else you'd expect i love i
was searching for um
project veritas recently because you
know they uh put out that music video oh
yeah oligarchy
yeah so i'm looking at project veritas
and i type in you know project and i can
see all the suggested
posts like youtube's like you know it
gives you suggestions as to what it
thinks you're trying to type
and then as soon as i typed in v-e-r it
just disappeared
all the suggestions were gone and then
it's like oh they figured out where i'm
going
and they don't like it they're not going
to autofill it for me how ridiculous is
that hoping that
i just search for project ver and then
get some random channel
maybe it's a good idea to create a
channel called project very for sure
and then just like you know talk about
project veritas and that's it
yeah then youtube will autofill project
very
project verit project verit dot verite
as
so that when people are searching for it
it autofills and then people will click
your channel instead
verituse with a you well no that
wouldn't i guess i suppose it would
autofill that in 2008
um i was really politically active on
youtube just like screaming
at the at the internet to that we have
the control now now that we have
internet video the president of the
united states president of russia can do
a video chat
and everyone can watch you don't need
secret service we're new in a new
paradigm
and i was talking and people were like
lighting up believing it and so cnn
wanted to get in on it
so they funded the cnn youtube debates
and for the first time in history they
took youtubers questions for the the
candidates
and it was the most i asked like about
the federal reserve i want to know why
the banking establishment co-opted our
government
no no no what they they had the most
cookie-cutter stuff but they were like
look how we're
part of this is cnn look how we're part
of this new uprising this new
and then it took about two or three
years by 2011 they'd completely co-opted
the
political conversation google yeah they
don't do anything like that anymore
no no and then they don't even do it
anymore they realize now they just
banned the comments on the white house
videos and
now they're you youtube's eliminating
thumbs down for joe biden because nobody
likes the guy
oh yeah they they love internet freedom
and social media when uh
when it was helping elect obama and
helping do coups in the middle east
but as soon as 2016 comes along and get
brexit and trump everything changes
you go back to 2012 you will see
articles in the wake of the obama
reelection like
facebook and the power of friendship and
you know its impact on the 2012 election
so they
they loved it for a while i think i
think shows like this and i mentioned
this before it's
is functions as a pressure release valve
for a lot of people who are frustrated
you know right now there's a lot of
people who are listening hearing us talk
about censorship and it's making them
feel good that their concerns are being
addressed
but youtube and facebook and twitter
knows that this conversation likely
won't result in anything meaningful
the republicans right now in response to
the trump announcement
are saying stupid things like it's time
to break up these big tech monopolies
and it's like
what no 20th century what are you
talking about facebook
face the reason facebook works is
because everyone uses it
you can't break facebook into 10
different facebooks then what all of a
sudden ian and i aren't on the same
network anymore
and so how does it work i suppose if
they break them up and force them to go
open source and like decentralize but
that would destroy the company outright
so it's not something that can be done
what needs to happen is regulation on
the platform that allows speech
however what's happening is there are
some people that youtube allows
and why is it that i see every day a
youtube channel get nuked for the
stupidest reason
or no reason at all but we're allowed to
keep doing the show why
like i said i think it's a pressure
release valve if they got rid of every
single
you know channel then you'd end up with
a whole bunch of people
losing it outright feeling like they've
been just booted out they have nothing
left and they go nuts
but they need good old you know milk
toast tim cast irl so that people are
like tuning in and hearing this and
going
yeah yeah it's good it's good to get the
truth and it is
but they also know that it's just enough
to keep people calm correct and you know
if you go
if you step out of line even a little
bit they'll uh they'll just ban you
so you know there are some things
everyone knows they can't say they ban
desantis
youtube band desantis because they
yelled a uh a covert 19 round table with
some of the signs of the great
barrington declaration
they outright banned him uh i think it
was a temporary suspension i believe but
you know there's a governor of britain
just you know
who will probably run for president in
2024. yeah well look you know
i said on twitter i think trump
shouldn't run because he's it's he's too
hot
as soon as as soon as trump pops his
head up every single
uninitiated liberal is going to be like
screaming and banging their head on the
wall just freaking out
and if you have someone like desantis
they'll still smear him they'll try
but desantis will not invoke the same
kind of anger that people had when it
was trump
well however i'll just say i i don't
think a republican can win you know a
lot of people are like maybe the
republicans can win in 2022 and even i
was saying it
the other day because libs have gone to
sleep i'm not confident because what's
gonna happen is
a conservative from 10 years ago will
never win
an election for a few reasons one the
modern republican party is more about
trump and populism than it was about
establishment conservatism
but more importantly if you even say
half the things that the democrats said
they'll call you far right and
they'll suspend you or shadow ban you so
what's going to happen is
a republican might win in 2024 but this
republican is going to be basically
bernie sanders
and then the democrats going to be you
know further left the full-blown
communists maybe not by 2024 but
certainly in the next you know 15 or 20
years
when all of our opinions are being
filtered through the far left lens of
silicon valley
conservatives get banned and the
remaining conservatives are the milk
toast centrist conservatives
and then 10 years after that those
people are fringe far right or banned
and the conservatives are going to be
socialist other kin or something
i mean when we're talking about you know
lots of people say you know 2020
election was stolen
uh but uh in a sense it was but it was
done in the open by silicon valley
censorship which they didn't even they
didn't even try to hide the censorship i
mean
we breitbart news found out that google
was censoring us through google's own
analytics tools
so they didn't they didn't care that we
how did that happen what did they say uh
so they introduced a major algorithm
change
around six months before the election
and right after that algorithm change
uh impressions and clicks on uh no
breitbart's visibility on uh on google
search for breitbart newslinks it
it went straight of a cliff like went
right down so it was clearly something
artificial haven't do a bunch of other
conservative sites as well and that
remained the case for uh
right until the action plus you could
search for
the exact string of breitbart news
headlines in google and the link
wouldn't come up
right same thing was happening that was
happening to my other channels as well
and it wasn't until i talked about it on
this show that one day people like oh no
your channels are back
you would take the exact title of my
videos and put it in google and it
wouldn't come up
so something happened around i think it
was like may of 2018
where is that was that when you noticed
the algorithm shift uh it was a little
bit later than i would say it was may of
uh
2020 2020 yeah so around six months
before the election
in may of 2018 there was
tons of people were talking about it you
could look in your analytics and check
your recommendations and you'd see just
one day i went boom to like
one it went from like 10 to like one
percent and then
people weren't getting any suggestions
anymore for any
political content that was deemed to be
you know
just anti-democrat anti-woke
and it's it's it's remarkable because
back then i said republicans were too
stupid to deal with
it that's still true today three years
later
they are still not smart enough to save
their own careers
and what's going to happen is by the
time any modern young
center right conservative type gets into
office then the system will be it'll be
too late
and you're not going to be able to get
elected because the conservative the
republicans at that point are going to
be socialists
well i i think um i'm a little bit more
optimistic because i think um
the the internet freedom that existed
before 2016
that that red pills a lot of people and
you know those people have not forgotten
they're still out there millions of
people
um and i think what what people need to
do is focus less on national elections
and more on activism at the local level
at the precinct level
you know influencing their local
republican party or their local democrat
party
because that's where you can start
change you know from the bottom up it's
much less competitive they don't need
thousands of birds you need hundreds or
dozens
and just at the state level get some at
this at the priests at the precinct
level when you go from the precinct
level
to the uh the county level to the the
state senate level to the state level
then why don't we just have like uh why
don't we start with like a small town
implementing these these common carrier
rules uh well no with common carry rules
you need the state but to influence the
state you need to get involved with the
precinct level yeah
so uh for example uh one of the bad
things i like the texas uh
tech bill but one of the bad things
texas did recently the texas republican
party
rather was uh issue emotion
uh taking the party off gab right right
yeah because of
concerns about uh anti-semitic hate
speech or whatever
and governor abbott supported that that
was uh
it's kind of weird that you know the
texas republicans are saying oh we're
going to support free
speech with this bill which hasn't
passed yet but we're also going to leave
the only you know free speech social
network
yeah so we have this from texas
scorecard texas
gop executive committee votes to delete
gab account
how did your state republican executive
committee members vote so this shows
i guess everyone how all these
individuals voted they say during their
quarterly meeting in laredo's past
weekend the state republican executive
committee voted 35-25
to delete the texas gop's gab account
after much debate consisting of one man
and one woman from each of the state's
31 districts
the srec is essentially the governing
body of the republican party
they go and say gab is an alternative
social media platform and uh
wow that's very stupid but yeah on the
one hand that's a black pill because the
party that's supposed to be
anti-censorship
uh and you know anti-smears of bigotry
and racism and anti-semitism things like
that
is doing stupid things like this but on
the other hand you know you look at this
this is the
executive committee of the gop party in
texas
it's not that hard to influence that if
you get involved at the local
level at the local precinct level and
send delegates to the gop convention
uh and you know make legislative
suggestions which anyone can do if
you're a member of the party there
so you know if more people did that this
would be a lot harder to do it feels
like
not just with these stories of a bunch
of other stories you know we've been
hearing about through the past months
the system is just rotten to its core
and i don't see how we pull out of this
uh
this tailspin the foundation is cracking
the it's
it's like a building you know and the
wood is rotten and the foundations are
crumbling
and people are trying to come in and
trying to hold the building up but it's
going down man
i don't i don't know look people can be
fairly optimistic but you take a look at
what's going on with antifa getting
released
you know they commit felonies and
they're free to go a woman you know
sells coffee and then she gets arrested
big tech keeps doing this the republican
party is
so pathetic and so weak
that they've known about this problem
for years and just sit there going
i don't know i think anybody that hides
behind a political party is pathetic and
weak
but then what what do you do start your
own party you don't need a problem sure
but that's right regardless the
foundation is broken because there's too
many people who are like i have to vote
republican otherwise a democrat will win
when you say the foundation is busted
and you the allegory of the building
falling down what is it
what is the the fount what is it the
system that you're talking about like
literally capitalism our country the
united states
the function of government and business
is rotten to its core
specifically just the united states i
mean other countries have other problems
i don't live in those other countries in
the united states so i can talk to you
about the us
i think other countries have problems
the uk they got a way worse
that country is on fire i know yeah a
lot of countries arresting a guy
for making a youtube video with his with
his girlfriend's dog
man those people are nuts but we got
that stuff happening here too
to a certain degree a guy getting
arrested for posting lap for for posting
rap lyrics and so those rap lyrics were
were threats of terrorism
it happens there was that ricky vaughn
case as a while guy getting arrested for
posting memes in 2016.
yeah that's interesting because which
was copied by a left-winger who was not
arrested
the meme was like giving false
information on how to vote or something
yeah but then i left foreign the exact
same thing imitating this and you know
she's just fine right
right yep she made a video i think
saying the same thing
yeah well this so so the justice system
is completely
at the at the whims of the extremists
you look at the chauvin trial you so
this is this is amazing
in the chauvin trial you have uh this
juror who lied
said he didn't go to these protests he
did the floyd family spoke there
then he claimed he doesn't remember
owning that george floyd shirt and then
jack bosobic not only found a picture of
him wearing it but found a video of him
in his own youtube channel
wearing the shirt this guy's clearly
lying and you know what's gonna happen
nothing there's not gonna be a new trial
the system is rotten to its core mark
zuckerberg can do whatever he wants
they call him in over and over and over
again nothing happens
they're just it's a pressure relief
valve the system is
is is corrupt there's democrats
extracting all they can from the system
as it burns to the ground and
republicans are just
also essentially getting as much as they
can out of it while it burns to the
ground
and just telling you they're giving you
enough to make you
think they're fighting back when they
are not
um the what was the 1600 checks they
sent everyone that are worth
sorry what were you going to say i was
going to say hashtag
notable republican senator bill hagerty
the the senator the new senator from
tennessee
has introduced a a big tech bill that's
actually good
that uh you know you know what i i
sure not all republicans um i like rand
paul
you know we we we're we're seeing the
praises of ron paul ron paul's a good
dude rand paul is pretty good
uh they're not all perfect i like this
thing about common cares but let me tell
you man
when the republicans had the power they
did nothing well they actually sided
with russiagate
that was in part because they weren't uh
feeling the pressure from the base when
they feel the pressure they actually
they actually flip pretty quickly i i
saw this firsthand during the uh the
confirmation of nathan simonton at the
fcc
uh this was this was a guy who i knew
personally was you know
not bought by special interests who was
opposed to tech censorship who'd worked
on efforts against tech censorship
uh but republican senators they weren't
an establishment guy there so they were
wavering you know if it was left up to
republican senators they wouldn't have
let this guy through
but uh you know at breitbart used it you
know article after article putting the
spotlight on each republican center that
was wavering
and like within you know days of doing
that the senators
all flip and said oh yes of course we'll
support trump's nomination to the fcc
it is possible to uh to accomplish
change through the system but only if
you like keep the spotlight on these
people like 24 7.
it's it's possible that because the the
traditional liberals have gone to sleep
now that the democrats have taken
everything
come 2022 conservatives and disaffected
liberals moderates the anti-woke
are in full offensive and the libs have
gone to sleep thinking they've won
so maybe in 2022 the republicans gained
back the house maybe they'll get back
the senate
maybe in 2024 they can give back the
presidency but i gotta say i'm not
confident that even if they do they'll
do anything
they're they look uh people like ted
cruz
you know i think he's better than most
of them but i still think
all of them are more worried about what
the new york times thinks of them
than what their their constituents do
that's true republicans need to start
ignoring the media this needs to be the
new paradigm
well everyone like with a with a
platform or in a position of influence
just ignore the media
absolutely stop participating in their
broken systems peop
these republicans are probably sitting
there thinking well if i actually do the
right thing they'll lie about me and
then i'll lose [ __ ]
that people won't want to donate to me
and corporations will get scared so i
better just toe the line for what the
media says
and thus the media dictates what
republicans do the republicans do just
enough to make it seem like they're
doing something and they do nothing
so what happens when the republicans
actually win back these seats
then all of a sudden you're going to see
them say well hold on we need to have a
hearing and slow down we can't just do
this
democrats on the other hand are like
rubber stamp at all the place on fire
they're getting paid massive amounts of
money to sit there and just
field questions and talk about stuff
they're getting paid
they don't barely do anything and then
they're getting bribed by corporations
to pass bills and devote yes on stuff
they haven't read
it's so busted how many how how
how many times how many elections are we
supposed to go through crossing our
fingers
right i think one of the issues too is
that millennials
have only have only experienced so many
election cycles
and so as the older generation starts to
fade out
and retire and stop paying attention or
pass on
then you end up with the next generation
of you know gen x's and millennials
who are just basing everything off of
we've been through four election cycles
and we've seen this that and this
this is the time this is our chance if
you took one person who was a thousand
years old he'd be like oh yeah this
again
we've gone back and forth with this like
hundreds of times yeah you're not going
to get what you want
the system is a is a gross amalgam of
weird corrupt policies that don't make
sense half the time
i think they'll also be like don't break
your country
don't break your country just come on
guys it's up to you no it's
it's it's broken well they're breaking
it they're being broken
setting fires i know for for over a year
the riots have been continuing
and then we get the fbi being like these
domestic these far-right terrorists are
the biggest threat and you're like
i i didn't have i didn't hear
helicopters and sirens outside my house
because of the far right i didn't have
to move an event i was putting on near
my home with with guest speakers
because of the far right the far right
was the terror it was the boogeyman
it was because antifa called and
threatened to burn the theater down yeah
it was because far left riders crossed
the bridge
and started riding in the suburbs yet i
turn on the tv
and you the system is dominated by the
cult these people who don't care
you know and i really believe a lot of
these people go on tv these like you
know chris ray or whatever
the fbi they they know they're lying of
course they do
but they don't care about you and they
don't all they care about is making sure
the new york times
is nice to them they're all more worried
about what the new york times has to say
than the people of this country there
was a solzhenitsyn quote about this
during the soviet union uh something
like uh
we know they're lying they know that we
know that they that they
they know that we know that they're
lying and we know that they know
that we know that they're that they know
that that's what it's getting to
that's the point we're getting to
there's a lot of traditional liberals
who don't know anything and it's the
best example is that they've all gone to
sleep they're no longer paying attention
to politics
the ratings are dropping they don't care
they never cared
and it's scary that these people are
empowering
sociopaths and psychopaths and that's
true for republicans too there's a lot
of conservatives who go to sleep all the
same
don't pay attention and that's why you
end up with a lot of never trumper
conservatives who just
all they cared for was the establishment
so i end up with with kenzinger in
illinois
getting all this support and getting
these votes because you've got people
who just don't care
dude i think they're on the way out i
think liz cheney's on her way out she
might lose her leadership position
kim zing is going to be redistricted out
there and he'll probably get like a
position on msnbc as a comment as a
ex-republican commentator
very popular uh but they're they seem
they do
at the moment they seem to be on their
way out of the party except for like you
know
the really smart ones like dan crenshaw
who like you know pretend to be all
maggot but are basically just
establishment
yeah but they have it's interesting that
they have to pretend to be mad
right because i think that there's a lot
of people who are uh
who woke up due to the internet they're
paying attention now they're getting
their facts they're watching shows like
this and they're realizing
you know the media is lying a lot but
the media is doing everything in its
power to make sure they can maintain the
facade so
one thing's gotta happen is youtube's
gotta gotta purge itself
youtube wants to be netflix they don't
wanna be youtube anymore let me ask you
a question what's
let's about everyone a question what's
worse big media or a big tech
big tech yeah tech why would you say i
would say big media why why would you
guys say
because big tech can block you from
talking your own mother correct but what
drives that i think big media dr has
driven most of the tech censorship
uh because you see this happen like
whenever facebook or youtube doesn't
move quickly enough i'm not saying you
know the
tech companies are blameless but
whenever they are they don't move
quickly enough
uh they'll start up these huge
advertiser boy because they do against
youtube against facebook
and the whole panic around
disinformation and fake news was started
by the media
right but that hadn't happened that
there would have been some pressure on
the tech companies to censor
but it's only because of the relentless
pressure from the media over the past uh
four or five years that this has
escalated so rapidly the hunter biden
story was censored by big tech before
there's any media
there were some tweets from journalists
well i think it's gone to the point now
that they're anticipating what the media
will do and what the democrats will do
the reason i said tech is because
they can build the algorithms that you
don't see and that like with media at
least you
see what they're feeding you and other
people are eating it
maybe you're not but at least you see it
that that's what they're eating but with
tech
algorithms you don't know like why am i
seeing the things i think i like
i don't know because some some scientist
in a room has decided that he wants me
to see it that way and
i can never know because the proprietary
i think i think over time youtube is
going to slowly excise channels like
this
they are doing everything in their power
to make it seem like that well they're
not they're not banning or censoring you
but they will reduce visibility slowly
over time
go open a private open open a private
window in a browser and then go to
youtube.com
and you'll be like wow is this what
people are watching yes because it's the
only thing they know
it's the only thing they know that
exists because it's what youtube gives
them
open up a new account on spotify here's
the music they're recommending to people
we are we are in this small space
of i guess i don't know what you'd call
it right
um initiated individuals i guess the one
we described the people who have paid
attention to politics who know what's
going on
and they're doing everything their power
to make sure that more people don't come
into the space
and just go back to sleep everything's
okay we're going to keep blowing up kids
in the middle east don't ask any
questions
take the blue pill absolutely had
weapons of mass destruction
actually he didn't but they told us that
for years
and that allowed us to invade iraq and
station troops and murder how many tens
of thousands or hundreds of thousands of
civilians lots of civilians
how many people have died hundreds of
thousands
this is the same companies that are
giving us the lies now about
the far this and the farther and the
extremists this and the color of that
guy's skin
and you know what the you know the best
thing about all of it is in 50 years
if they if they win no one will ever
talk about this conversation
no one will remember yeah it'll be it'll
be in the history books it won't be in
the history books
it'll be purged it'll be excised from
the from the uh the great
libraries of the digital cloud
and uh it'll never have happened as soon
as these generate the generation that
we're in
passes if they have their way and it
sounds like nothing's going to stop them
because the republican party is a bunch
of feckless losers
then we end up in 50 years with the
republican party is a bunch of socialist
other kin
arguing with communist transhumanists
who
have already integrated their you know
bodies into robot bodies
and i made this joke on twitter but it's
not even it's not meant to be a joke
it's it's the truth in in 15 years
you're gonna have a young republican
being like everybody knows that
socialism is good but these communists
are too far left
that's the way it's been going you can
see it happening absolutely
you could you you just need only look
back a little bit to the 90s
look back to the 2000s when bernie
sanders is like we need a border barrier
hillary clinton carrie all these people
like bill to build the wall
then trump's like okay build the wall
how dare you you're far right
open borders now the the people who used
to protest
the the world trade organization is
hilarious the battle the battle for
seattle or whatever the battle in
seattle remember that
late night i think was late 90s huge
world trade organization protest
it was the left saying no to this big
free trade internationalist policy
now they're for open borders the
oligarchy co-opted their own uh
their own opponents uh actually an
interesting article by uh
an angelo cody villa former senator
uh he's out the claremont institute
and i'm sort of arguing it's myself
there because i said you know is big
media worse than big tech
but what this article argues is that
they're all interchangeable like the guy
who
runs the fbi the guy who runs facebook
the democrat politician the democrat
president
all of the guy who runs cnn all of them
are interchangeable elites working
towards
the same girl the guy who runs the
activist organization also
interchangeable they trade places
and they all want the same thing which
is to reduce the power of the people
and increase the power of the elites
check this out
from the washington washington examiner
black lives matter releases
new list of demands including
permanently banning trump from all
digital media platforms
why why does black lives matter care
about one guy i thought black lives
matter was about
empowering empowering you know the black
community and stopping the you know
police brutality
but i guess they're really concerned
with making sure the democrats win
that's one of their one of their new
demands
so this is it this is this is the proof
that their goal is to rewrite history
and control from this point on history
if nothing changes in 50 years
trump may as well not existed i once had
a very long
uh phone conversation with a uh facebook
press representative who is
supposed to just give me like a canned
comment for my article
but instead he went on for 30 minutes
trying to persuade me that black lives
matter is not a political movement
and when i say that facebook is
political because it supports blm i'm
wrong because
black lives matter is non-partisan and
non-political and everyone should
believe in black lives
but yes this non-part is a non-political
organization wants to uh to ban
a uh one that wants a president to be
banned from office what do you think
we'll say about donald trump in 50 years
at this at this space
they're going to say he was uh he was a
white supremacist
they say he was a violent white
supremacist he incited insurrection
and tried to destroy the country and he
was dutifully defeated
by a powerful and well-informed
electorate who challenged the fake news
ecosystem that he had created
that that'll that'll be history the
pictures of him will make him look
grotesque he'll have a bright orange
face with tiny hands
and that's all people will know about
him i
i disagree with that i think what
they'll say is uh that this current
republican candidate is way too extreme
even donald trump was more moderate than
that
you know this is this is how it always
goes the last republican
uh president was a moderate and the uh
the car the current republican president
of canada is way too far way beyond
there so george bush is now a hero
whereas you know at the time he was you
know literally hitler yeah but you look
at george bush now and george bush is
parroting the establishment and the
welcome left
so joy which loves him now but back but
back then they were like you know
uh you know that this good this guy uh
he's racist he hates black he doesn't
care about black people
but he's wondering he's hitler blah blah
blah but they call they call john mccain
a racist
and they're called romney sexist and you
know now these are all heroes of the
establishment
so trump was a moderate though compared
to them and they called him far right
indeed yeah so they can't have you know
it's hilarious watching uh you know
looking at cnn
and and you know the the twitter
accounts of some of their personalities
when they're just trapped in this time
vortex where january 20th has never come
and they're stuck there with trump all
around them
and there and the things they say about
him i'm like wikipedia
and uh look universities in academia is
totally corrupted and tainted with bunk
insane information they push lies every
day
you go on reddit you see what people
think they think wrong things
because the media is no longer about
mainstream corporate press
is it for a long time has not been
around to inform people
it exists now to misinform people on
purpose
someone got smart and they were like man
you know these journalists maybe it was
the mob maybe it was these corrupt
politicians back in the day
they're like this journalist is going to
expose my affair
i can't have that i know let's buy the
newspapers well
goebbels uh hitler's prophet minister of
propaganda was
legit led spearheaded that charge when
they had they had basically had
the first time in history they had tv
and they could use media like
that so they decided if you tell a lie
enough
eventually people will start to believe
it i wouldn't be surprised if people are
in the future
told that there were weapons of mass
destruction in iraq and that it was
it was trump's white supremacist
followers who are spreading lies i
wouldn't even surprise other people
today that think there were
like you would think that would be the
most red flag
we made a mistake thing to teach kids
but they don't want that
and i say they and i hate using they as
a bland thing but this this military
complex whatever you want to call it
military
capitalist course of com whatever
they they really want to sell bullets
they need to
and they're afraid that if we don't
police the world someone else will
i think it's way way more than that i
think that's that's overly simplistic
yeah i'm being kind because we're on tv
on the internet yeah on the internet i i
don't think it's about necessarily
selling bullets about maintaining
dominance
and it's not so much they're scared
someone else will police the world it's
that
they want to maintain dominance
everybody wants more
i think it's i think it's fair to say
there's concerns about china's expansion
in russia
but if they were really cared about if
they really cared about that i'd imagine
they'd be taking china more seriously
not being deferential to china
i think the reality is many politicians
are like look
i don't care who's in charge so long as
you keep giving me money
and i get to be super rich so when china
starts doing its thing they go
what's the easiest way to make money on
this one just side with china
yeah the way to understand american
foreign policy i think is that it
for a long time it hasn't been in the
interest of the american people or in
even the american national interest in
terms of maintaining dominance
it's just been you know which foreign
lobbyists are throwing around money
which think tanks are
throwing around money that that you know
that the whole russia panic was driven
by these very powerful influential cross
atlantic think tanks like the atlantic
council
um and you know the german marshall fund
you know who their entire job is
predicated on a u.s
focus on russia so at the slightest hint
that there might be a pivot from russia
to china these guys freaked out which is
why they became some of the most
anti-trump people out there
yep yeah so history is written by the
victors yeah
and but then again there are also you
know people have an interest in a china
focus so it's just all these groups
competing
man i'm a bit uh i don't the right word
is
pessimistic to say the very least there
are some there are some positive things
we've seen the olympics just banned uh
black lives matter protests kneeling
you know pumping your fist or whatever i
think you know we've seen some
some hollywood stuff stuff that's been
anti-woke and it may be because now that
trump's out of office they're like okay
we better pull this back before we lose
control
but regardless the establishment is in
control
i've heard a cynical interpretation of
the olympic thing if the olympic
committee allowed political expression
by
you know american athletes that have to
allow political expression from chinese
athletes
and north korean athletes actually it's
north korea banned from the limits i
don't know but all these authoritarian
regimes would send their athletes and
say hey uh
you know show that show the hammer and
sickle you know uh you know
holder holder sign saying you know the
hong kong protesters are terrorists et
cetera et cetera
yep so they'd have to cave to all these
other countries as well that's probably
why they did it it's true and and i'd
love to see more protests against china
but
i'm i'm they're still allowed to protest
just not during the games
so i'm like i mean that's a good thing
maybe everybody needs to chill out a
little bit this is like you know the
violence the escalation
the problem is it's one-sided it's it's
the
the people protesting china aren't going
around blowing things up i mean hong
kong there was
you know rioting but you look at in in
the us it's antifa
and and they're gaining ground and
they're winning they're winning the
legal battle they're winning the media
battle
and the federal law enforcement
is acting like they don't exist and and
giving them space to just destroy
everything
to inject some optimism the state laws
against critical race theory
that's a positive development lots of
red states doing but but you know when
you were talking about the florida
florida's law
on uh social media censorship not being
enough
yeah it's the same thing that's true for
these bans on critical race theory it's
not just critical race theory it's it's
it's wokeness encompasses critical
theory in general
which is every aspect of identity so now
you've got a whole bunch of people
saying critical race theory and they're
totally ignoring
critical gender theory and you know
there's a whole slew of identity-based
you know theories that exist beyond race
so it's like better than nothing but
still
how are we supposed to catch up if if
we're going slower than they are
they're not just passing laws they're
burning down
buildings cutting cutting off pigs heads
and putting on the porches
of the of the former home of one of the
witnesses in the chauvin trial
they're lying to get on the trials in
the first place and the good
principled you know moderates and
disaffected liberals and conservatives
are like well we're not going to do any
of that we shouldn't
and if you even think about doing it the
fbi will go oh
and they'll send 12 agents down because
they found a garage pole rope in your
house
yeah the fbi is just like the
enforcement arm of the uh the democrat
controlled oligarchy at this point
it was it was during trump as well it
was yes yeah
yeah so uh forgive me for being a little
bit pessimistic huh
you know what well politically yeah i
think it's busted
af but i think the real solution is
technology like if we can
have water um decentralized water supply
for every human and we're able to
travel and live spread out i think a lot
of these problems will dissipate
so although it is important to focus on
these this political stuff
china america black lives matter
violence in the streets
but it's not the solution i don't think
it's the solution i have no amount of
arguing and yelling and signing
paperwork's gonna solve it we need
technology that can allow us to become
independent
yeah the technology is currently owned
and controlled by the cult so
proprietary technology is concerning in
ip
wasn't even invented so i think queen
elizabeth uh created
copyright in order to protect the bibles
that she wanted to sell so that she
could maintain
profit on all the bibles before that
that didn't exist you could just kind of
trade information freely
i think ip should exist well i mean
should be reformed
somebody with software code i think
somebody who works you know 100 hours to
make a feature-length film
should be compensated for producing that
work and people
saying it's just information i can share
it all i want it's like okay like
someone worked really hard to make
something they want to sell that's why
crypto works that's why crypto is so
powerful
because you can't duplicate it it's it's
it's a it's a non-duplicatable asset you
can have digitally
i like the idea like if you made a movie
and wanted to sell it for 9.99 for
someone to watch it and then i
got a hold of it and wanted to sell it
for a buck for people to watch it
that 90 of those profits would go to you
automatically
so if you could somehow code into the
software that no matter
where it goes and who profits off of it
always goes back to the creator
at least a large percentage we're i'm
getting off off topic a little bit yeah
this is
yeah i guess the main topic is i'm
interested in this actually i mean i
think uh
you were saying earlier about how all
these uh hollywood studios
would judge regurgitate stuff and you
know do the same formulas again and
again the same remakes again and again
if they didn't have full control of the
if they didn't have full control over
the ips
and you know as you say if people out
you know reproduce and uh create new
stuff
off of that ip and all the profits or a
significant amount of the profits go
back to the
creator then i think you'd see a lot
more creativity
yeah definitely creative commons things
like that i don't know though it's it's
decentralized from the internet you know
there used to be a small amount of
really big bands and movie producers and
movie stars who made a lot of money
and now because movie theaters are going
away and because spotify exists and
everything's decentralizing
this is actually what i think is
contributing to the destruction of
our culture and society that people can
choose
whatever they want so it used to be that
everybody's like what do you watch well
you can watch the news you can watch the
oscars
so everybody would watch the oscars
whether they liked it or not it was what
was on
now the oscars comes on it's like what
did we watch during the oscars i don't
remember we watched something oh
mortal kombat i was watching mortal
kombat instead because it came out
the movie it's the citizen kane of our
generation excellent excellent film
yes just just totally amazing and i
didn't watch the oscars
it's so extreme too how many videos are
on youtube guess
the billions billy you have billions of
choices of things to watch during the
oscars you used to have like
70 maybe if you had like five before
that you had five yeah abc nbc
now you have billions of things to watch
st static things that always are there
to watch there's no schedule there's no
you have to wait till eight o'clock i
mean it's a different reaction this is
why elites are so scared of the internet
though because it's taken away that
shared reality
and you know there were downsides to
taking away a shared reality but it took
away a shared reality that they
controlled
and that's what they're afraid of right
now people
find whatever community they want for
whatever they want to believe
and then you end up with people
believing in saying things so it's funny
i i love how
you know cnn is obsessed with like q
anon and and trumpism
and i'm just like the level of damn like
the
the level of cultism within like the
fringe
q anon people is identical to the
zealotry
of the woke left but the woke left is
institutionally accepted
spouting ridiculous insane fake news
nonsense
every single day i think i think one of
the most uh
dangerous people on tv i love left is
like tucker carlson is dangerous
i actually think one of the most
dangerous would probably be like
chris cuomo and uh tapper
and then to a lesser degree you know
people like brian selter their jobs are
to misinform you to make sure you don't
understand the world
it's like they're purposefully trying to
make you see things incorrectly so that
you can't do anything about it
case in point i think it was was a
tapper when he was like was he the one
who said you couldn't look at the
wikileaks documents
or was that cuomo it was one of them
definitely one of them they were like
don't don't forget these wikileaks
emails you can't look at them it's
illegal but we're allowed to do it
and then they can all all right what
they want to make sure you don't
know things brian stelter on history
goes don't watch the spin make sure you
come to us
we're the only ones who can bring you
the truth i'm like you guys are crazy
yeah i mean you look at the shared
reality created by you know
institutional
uh corporate media you know they believe
in sane things about you know white
supremacy and
feminism and the patriarchy and they
believe this for decades and decades and
i think
the other q and on thing they're just
insane that they now have to compete
with other
insane realities i mean the q anon thing
is not relevant in my opinion
it's i mean sure there's a lot of people
on the internet who believe things that
are not true
i know people who believe the earth is
flat because they went on the internet
and read some weird
website then i open vox and they're
repeating
fringe conspiracy theories they did it
for years
bill maher i love how i love how uh it's
one of the sweetest things like one of
the funniest things
to see bill maher get corrupted because
he's this proud like rational guy
who's like oh religion is crazy and i
think and oh these republicans are so
dumb
and now it's like he's coming out
admitting yeah russia gate wasn't real
it's like but dude for years you were
prattling on about it
did you not take two seconds out of your
day you
spineless coward to actually read the
news
no because people at this age and this
point in their careers
they sit back with their eyes half
closed bill maher probably sparked up a
doobie and then said just do the work
for me i'm done and so then some dumb
intern turns on cnn and just writes down
what he says here bill here's your
criticism
and then bill comes out a week after
covington
a week after covington when everything
was debunked
and says all of the the bs lines and i'm
like bro
do you have google well uh you know what
i can't blame them because google's
banning certain news
exactly they're pointing him to
confirmation bias a lot of
times people are getting pointed towards
articles that confirm what they want to
believe
and now he's he's supposed to be the
same the same liberal guy
i appreciate the fact that he pushes
back on the wokeness
but his talking points are just
regurgitated fake news and the dude
doesn't have the wherewithal to actually
know what he's
talking about more so than many others
to be fair they want us to you know
uh believe that the scariest most
dangerous conspiracy theories are the
ones on you know anonymous message
boards
but the conspiracy theories we should be
worried about are the ones that exist in
universities and in the cnn
newsroom because they're the ones that
have influence yeah like the uh
project veritas exposing the technical
director who's like we got trump out
it's what we do
and we're going to be fearmongering
going covet death oh man gangbusters for
ratings these people are
sick what do you think is more dangerous
conspiracy wise the world economic
forums great reset
or cnn putting coveted numbers at the
top of the screen
for emotional manipulation uh i think
that they're both put they're both
pretty dangerous which is
kind of dodging the question but um it
goes back to my point that you know no
one's shared reality is going to be
perfectly absent
off you know nonsense because we all end
up believing nonsense based on you know
what our in group believes
and we all confirm our own biases the
one the uh
therefore the ones we should be most
critical of the the shared realities we
should be most uh
alert to are the ones that come from
universities and the mainstream media
and these big organizations like the
world economic forum because those
institutions have power
whereas you know random anonymous
message board with q posters does not
i think a lot of what we're seeing is
great reset stuff you know
so they're they're it was interesting
someone made the point that when they
announced 15 days to slow the spread
mark zuckerberg said we're not going to
reopen until next
june you know like a year from now or
whatever and then sure enough
that's when a bunch of the states are
lifting their their lockdowns as if
mark zuckerberg knew or it's a
coincidence whatever the point is a lot
of these businesses took action
whether it mattered to the pandemic or
not a lot of
these states were doing things that had
nothing to do with pandemic
for for instance there was a woman in
north new jersey
who was selling things on facebook
online she had a little resale
shop and when they shut all the
businesses down she was in her business
and she was filming things saying
if you see anything you like just let me
know and we'll ship it out and the cops
showed up
with a smile on their face and said
ma'am you can't do what you're doing
and she was like what do you mean we're
they're like you have to close your
storage because we are closed
no ma'am you can't live stream your
products and then sell them
what does that have to do with covid and
why did these cops go and do it
those cops should be fired but uh they
were like
25 percent of people who have not left
their homes throughout all of kerber
something insane like that
that that serious delusion that uh you
know people want to talk about
q and stuff like those people i'm scared
of those people i'm terrified of these
people because
they vote and it's it's like you see
these videos there's one video recently
of a woman wearing it's like she made
out of pvc
pvc pipe this like the square rectangle
that goes over her body with plastic
sheets
and then like her hands can come out
through gloves
and she's walking around with this thing
you see videos i wonder how many of
these are jokes
right because we bought the space helmet
thing which is really funny i have this
thing it's called like
micro climate and it's like a space
helmet i got i got to admit though
i bought it as a gag because it was
funny but it's really useful when i'm
cleaning out the garage and there's all
the dust and pollen and
you know i would i would go in there you
know and i'd try to clean out the dust a
bit and i'm sneezing like crazy and i'm
like i'm gonna wear my space helmet
and it works it's beautiful it's big and
it's got air filters in it there's
actually really no advertisements you
didn't
know you needed yeah maybe they should
market it as like when you're cleaning
in a dusty place
yes and you need filters because of you
know yeah and for your eyes too
but anyway you have a lot of these
people who who believe the most insane
things these videos where like
people are walking down the street
wearing you know a hazmat
suit or something and they jump out of
the way of people i
have friends and it's like dude i get it
i understand there's a concern about
covid
but some people just go nuts yeah i mean
i understand if you like in a vulnerable
uh
vulnerable group if you're older or if
you have some sort of condition that
makes you particularly at risk to due to
covert
but like normal healthy people are doing
this like okay
it's it's not just the lockdown it's
like the extremism it's the wearing the
weird
hazmat suits with like an air canister
gutted me of
everything i've seen in the last two
years is the baby when the baby was born
in plastic and then the mom like pressed
it against her
all the pressing the baby's face against
the plastic sheet
so it was protected i don't know i don't
know it was just
so sad to be a for the baby's first
experience in life to be smushed into
plastic um
right right the point i'm trying to get
to is that there are a lot of people who
believe in saying conspiracy theories
that are unfounded
not even the mainstream media is saying
it but there's no criticism from
journalists over what
crazy people are saying you gotta
because you gotta be so careful because
you can get banned for criticizing
specific things you don't even know what
they are i'm not saying that i'm saying
cnn's brian selter will never come out
and say
antifa is a problem he's done it like
when andy no got attacked he did a blurb
where he's like a journalist shouldn't
get attacked
see i there we go anyway moving on
tucker carlson by the
way they won't do it so yes we all know
q anon is bad
we all know these people believe crazy
things and they never seem to give up
we don't talk about the fringe far left
conspiracies
the the lunatics who believe in saying
you know insane things about like
i i the left always tries to disavow
this like what conspiracies well there's
like a whole bunch of weird
medicinal websites that are run by
crystal woo-woo people who are leftists
who are socialists who are hippies on
farms who believe in saying things about
medicine
and about hospitals the media doesn't
talk about that
they they talk about anti-vaxxers but
they only ever highlight like a
conservative or just like some random
person on the internet
they don't talk about russiagate
literally four years of the mainstream
media propping up
completely fake news and and they still
do it every single day
so uh it's gonna be it's gonna be
fantastic look this this bill in florida
maybe they won't be able to actually
enforce these things there's a provision
saying that
news organizations can't be banned based
on their content i have
i look i'll prophase it by saying i know
loyal but like the lawyers i have talked
to say
it's extremely difficult for that to get
past the the first amendment unless you
also have some kind of common carrier
or public accommodation requirement i'll
say this about the the florida bill
though it does have a pretty strong
transparency requirement
that can't be dodged uh you know by
appeals of the constitution or to 230.
so that could be interesting it might
force these tech companies to really
know
show us what's going on with their
algorithms or they might just do that
and say okay yeah we are sentencing you
we don't care
what are you going to do at the very
least a bunch of lawsuits will be filed
at the state level
yep yep that will happen and then what's
facebook going to do they're going to
deal with
i mean we talked about the other day you
got 21 million people in in florida
let's say a little around half of them
are republicans
around 20 are probably paying attention
on social media because that's the
number on twitter and two percent of
those are active on twitter actually
posting
so you can have between a couple hundred
thousand or
you know tens of thousands of people and
millions of people
who might actually have issue with these
social media companies
many of them might file lawsuits and
have grounds to do so
they don't mind but it's doubtful in my
view that any of those will you know
survive in court i think the tech
companies will win
now the team at the state level at the
state level now the uh but how if they
if the state passes the law and then
they go to a court in that state and say
see what your law says that's what they
did the tech companies will just take it
to the federal they would have to appeal
to the feds but that still means they're
going to be
attacked on multiple fronts that they
have to pay for these lawyers
they're going to have to take it to
court and it's gonna cost them a lot of
money and they're not gonna get their
court costs back
uh not that much not not uh it's
very hard to impose financial
consequences on the tech companies that
they actually care about
and it would have to exceed the
financial costs that the media can
impose on them by whipping up ad
boycotts
and that's like hundreds of uh billions
billions well the
the problem ultimately is none of these
things individually it's our community
it is that we don't care about each
other or our country we have no [ __ ] no
shared interests no shared goals
every the country is split not just down
the middle because
sure there's a culture war with a left
and a right whatever that you know
whatever those factions may be
but there are subcategories within these
factions that are fighting with each
other that dislike each other
the states are another instance of you
know factional conflict
and these boycotts are the most insane
i'm sorry these these corporations and
the ad boycotts are the stupidest things
ever
you know you see coke now backtracking
oh no we didn't mean to criticize
georgia
it's just absolutely insane that these
corporations
are deciding to sacrifice their business
for like seven percent of the country
one way to look at it is that
centralization is fighting
decentralization
like the internet has busted up
everyone's shared realities we're now
going into you know the realities we
like best
but uh the the forces of centralization
are trying to fight that by suppressing
all these
idiots and imposing one shared
progressive worldview on everyone
what needs to happen is the law needs to
follow
uh the trend of decentralization and
actually create
and culture needs to create more
tolerance you know diverse viewpoints
because
viewpoints are getting more diverse as
you know shared reality breaks down
right
i see why the centralization is is doing
that because
historically if uh if a culture would
permeate or break apart
it would be taken over by outside forces
so they're they want to make sure it's a
strong but if we
if we evolve the decentralized system so
that it communicates properly with
itself
then we should still have similar
security to a centralized system
maybe they they maybe they really do
like that it's breaking down maybe it's
just uh
i mean look the great reset this uh
it's funny when i see people on twitter
say it's a conspiracy theory and i'm
like but here's their website it's the
world economic forum it's the davos
group it's
a bunch of extremely wealthy and
powerful individuals around the world
saying they're doing this and they're
going to do it here's what they're going
to do and they're all woke
yeah the conspiracy isn't that it exists
the conspiracy is
the actual thing they're doing it's it's
it's not a theory it's a conspiracy fact
small group of people
decided to make make some moves and make
some stuff happen
i guess conspiracy implies crime so
they're not literally advocating for
crimes they're saying everybody should
have a stake in the globe and
look what's happening the price of wood
and
steel have skyrocketed bacon coffee
chicken everything's
inflating like crazy the gold to lumber
ratio is nearing one it's at 1.1 or
something what does it mean exactly
so i i don't know exactly but it's a
it's it's it's it's
been this way before it's supposed to be
a good sign
that there's going to be some kind of
normalization but it does show that
lumber is skyrocketing up to gold gold
isn't going down so it's inflationary
which means your savings will become
worthless
your salaries will need to go up
substantially but what's going to happen
is there's going to be a period where
people can't buy things
you're not gonna be able to build a new
house you're not gonna be able to expand
your company and buy and
have new projects there's going to be a
very serious recession maybe even a
depression
and that means your savings will be
worthless
people people need to understand this
man they don't they don't understand how
dangerous it is
it's one of the reasons doge and
ethereum and bitcoin are probably
skyrocketing
because not that look i'm sure the meme
has a lot to do with it
dogecoin haha it's so funny it was at 63
cents or something 67 cents
at one point but it's a lot of people
saying
i don't want to have us dollars right
now so what can i do with it
oh here's a meme people have confidence
in this thing
i'll buy some of that but bitcoin and
ethereum have real value ethereum as a
function as an actual
uh tool function for a lot of different
services and bitcoin just as
a a digital store of value and first in
best dressed
so people are trying to find a way to
not hold us dollars i certainly
that's certainly my perspective which is
why gold and silver are are you know
also on my mind as well
i think people need to understand if you
work right now for one hour
and that one hour of labor gives you
enough currency to buy
you know maybe a meal at a restaurant if
you hold on to that
in four months that will not be able to
buy you anything anymore
that money that you had that one point
could have bought you that chicken
dinner
won't be able to buy you even a soda
that's what inflation means
it means the labor you do is constantly
being devalued as time goes on
so you need to put your money somewhere
where the value is retained stored or
will increase
and inflation by definition means that
it's getting bigger faster
so the the less valuable it gets the
faster it gets less valuable
that's otherwise it would be a linear
deflation it is
it is if that's such a thing a linear
deflation people think it can't happen
here
oh it can happen people think it can't
happen in 1928 1929.
people lost everything they put all they
they borrowed
bought stock on loans and then when the
stocks tanked they lost they had to pay
back loans
with money they didn't margin calls so
they called in the loans
but they were encouraged to do it by the
financial industry of course of course
of course
you so you take a look at uh weimar
germany and the photos of people
shoveling you know worthless marks in
the street
you look at venezuela it could happen
here and people think it can't and i'm
like no it can
maybe maybe uh we don't know when or why
but it's really amazing how we've had
such a long period of sustained
prosperity that people just can't fathom
hardship i think they're gonna do a
currency recall where they say give us
your dollars and for every dollar you
list we're gonna give you a token
of this new currency and you have two
years after two years your dollars are
worth zero
and that's a hard stop the funny thing
is they can just say that right
if like you know biden came out right
now and said the us dollar is no longer
going to be backed by the us government
then people would be like uh 20 dollars
all these people hiding
cash in their under their mattress
that's the stupidest thing too you saw
that story about the grandfather who
who hid 50 grand in their floorboards 50
grand you know
67 years ago was hundreds of thousands
of dollars in buying power
should have stored some gold in that box
should have stored some dogs
70 years ago buy some doge and
in like 20 years so some people have
been saying that dogecoin is going to be
cash because it can be it can it never
stops getting printed right there's no
oh yeah that works much better as a
currency than bitcoin does
right right so so bitcoin uh it's funny
because people are saying the current
state of bitcoin defies the
original intent of bitcoin it's a
deflationary currency though
there's there's entropy this coins will
slowly just be lost and destroyed
and eventually they can't be produced
anymore so the value can only go up
doge can be printed and is made forever
so a lot of people are like that's why
doge is better as a currency because the
money market can expand with the economy
would it not be the greatest thing ever
if one doge became one dollar and
and it stayed there forever the buying
power of a dollar right now
and it just normalized and then in 50
years
people are like you know pulling up
their phone like how much for the uh the
whopper meal
at 43 doge okay and they scan their
phones and it's not even a joke anymore
it's just literally just doge like yo
toss me 50 doge man i want to go pick up
some pizzas
and you're like all right dude and you
swipe your phone you're like hook it up
they're like cool cool
how many shibuyas do you think got
bought in 2021 so far
is that the type of dog that it is yeah
that's the type of yeah how many i think
we're adopted over
i bet it's increasing 12 months yeah
power to the shiba we know
right it would be funny if doge becomes
the i don't think
i don't think it will i think it's good
that bitcoin has a finite supply so that
you can't over inflate it like some
crazy guy can't be like i'm gonna print
a hundred trillion and keep 990 billion
of them
um but that will just keep making new
currencies that have finite supplies
and you know ahead of time what we're
getting into and that's how we'll be
able to have an infinite supply
i don't know what do we think biden's
going to do about crypto i think it's
more than likely that he's going to try
and clamp down on it some way
maybe but i wonder if they're gonna do
fed coin you know they've been they've
been talking about the federal reserve's
gonna make their own crypto
and it was interesting i was talking to
uh i was talking to somebody about how
banking works anyway
because like your bank account there's
no real dollars there
the bank doesn't have the cash if
everybody
if everybody went to the bank right now
and asked for their cash they'd be like
that cash doesn't exist
it's it's in your account you can spend
it you can't physically hold it
so it's a really interesting way to
avoid a potential run on the banks for
instance right
back in the day people went to the banks
like give me my money because they were
worried the bank loaned too much out
there wouldn't be
any available but now the bank can be
like we can't give you your money but
here's a debit card that still works
you can still buy things with it because
your money is all digital
and i was talking to someone and they
said i was like how do they track
whether or not their money's actually
there
it's just it's it's like an archaic kind
of blockchain essentially
that institutions will track money went
from discount to this account
and here's the account numbers and it
goes to that kind of discount and
there's a ledger showing
all the transactions that were made and
that's it no actual exchange of currency
no hard exchange of any physical object
so then someone makes the blockchain and
it's like they kind of just decentralize
what the banks were already doing
some centralized digital currencies have
a real value in venezuela
a lot of people uh bought and still buy
world of warcraft gold
because it was more stable and beautiful
than the venus
still even to this day because you can
buy gold now on world of warcraft well
that's the thing they were they were
either farming the guild in world of
warcraft or they were like transferring
their currency to world of warcraft girl
because
uh world of warcraft girl was less
likely to inflate than venezuela and
bolivars
yeah but world of warcraft gold inflated
like crazy oh yeah
oh yeah i'm not saying it's stable but
it's pr it was more stable for a time
than venezuela's currency
yeah that's kind of a that's a very
serious indictment of venezuela
but i wonder when when we get hit by
that there was i was reading one article
where there's some big investor guy said
30 market hit at the end of the year of
this year
yeah 30 percent so i'm not gonna tell
anybody what they should or shouldn't do
but i'm gonna buy a bunch of ethereum
me too yeah big ethereum update in july
yeah yeah you were saying they're not
gonna have mining costs anymore
uh yeah so they're gonna change the way
gas fees work
so uh i don't know all of the details
but it's gonna stop going to miners
miners are not happy about this
and it's going to instead some some of
it will be burned with every transaction
so it's going to make ethereum more
deflationary
oh so instead of paying the miners
you're paying less of a fee but the fee
is
just being that's that's very
interesting
but the bottom line is it's uh they're
planning it to make uh gas fees less
wild than they are today
if you can build a way to naturally
deflate currency into the currency
that's how you avoid inflation obviously
it just guarantees it becomes more and
more valuable over time because there's
less of it
or it doesn't become less valuable
however you want to look at it that's
really weird
i mean i i do think that there's a
possibility that doge shows us the
system is collapsing as well
in that there are people who got rich
big time for no reason for a meme it's
it's a meme economy it's almost like
labor is is essentially meaning
think about this way imagine you're a
contractor i'm sure a lot of people
watching are contractors
you build uh pole barns or something or
or some small structures
and you're like it's going to cost you
know ten thousand dollars for this you
know simple steel garage you wanted
and the guy goes uh hold on let me sell
some doge uh here you go man
and then you're like you should give me
10 grand to build this thing for you
and you're like you're selling doge what
does that mean oh yeah yesterday
i bought a bunch of doge and it jumped
30 30 you know 30 cents
doubling its value so now i'm just
giving you i didn't do any work for it
but now you're you're getting what you
want
we are living in that world there was a
moment in january where like
uh in the same day i was you know
walking through my apartment building i
i overheard a conversation between two
people oh yeah my dog investment's doing
really well
uh went to a restaurant the waitress was
talking about how her boyfriend made a
thousand dollars from joke everyone was
talking about it investing in it
that's why i i confidence is all that
matters
you know people thought for a while
people were saying litecoin was
the silver to bitcoin's gold and
litecoin is particularly valuable
bitcoin cash is up significantly
but it's all about confidence bitcoin
has confidence
big companies have invested in bitcoin
infrastructure dogecoin
has the second most level of confidence
in my opinion
the issue is that there's so much doge
it's a there's there's
a massive quantity of this it's probably
better to say ethereum has more
confidence
but i think doge is is art might be even
more than bitcoin to be honest
for a few reasons regular a regular
person who looks at bitcoin and sees
sixty thousand dollars
says i can't buy it because they don't
realize that you can buy
fragments you can you know down to the
eighth decimal point but they see a doge
and they're like 60 cents oh i'll put 10
bucks in
yeah and doge is so volatile it goes up
and down so steeply that there's always
going to be like
a significant dip that you can buy in it
dude it goes up and down so fast because
of the meme
if you there are programs you can buy
that's buy and trade on algorithms
and you press start and at the end of
the day you made 10 grand wow
because what it does is it has a certain
amount of money in a certain amount of
doge
and it buys low and sells high
automatically and looks for trends
probably like when a tumbles start to
happen and
get in and out it's really simple it's
like doge hits
you know yeah so like if there's a
certain percentage spread
it'll sell when it's high and then when
it dips back down it'll buy again
and then if it's a certain period of
time where it's only going up it'll just
buy in and then sell high
and it keeps doing this and it keeps
increasing the amount of currency and
those you have
so they're they people have been doing
this for since the inception of
cryptocurrencies
i remember back in the day there was one
website i remember what it was called
but they had
hundreds of clones of bitcoin and people
would just make simple programs
that would buy and trade whenever one
would go up it would go down they'd buy
when it got they would sell and they
should do with all the different
currencies
people made a ton of money oh i got to
find these doge algorithms
it's it's it's not even a it's it's it's
really simple it's like if increased
five percent
sell if decreased five percent buy it's
like
really ridiculously simple and so it
just sits there tracking the current
price
and it's going up and down and then it
buys it it sells and then it buys and it
sells and it buys and it slowly goes up
getting you more doji and more cash
that's that's due to the volatility of
doge i mean day traders do this in
general
and you look for a particularly stock
you think is going to spike and then as
soon as does you sell it immediately and
then move on and you don't worry about
it
but uh i i do wonder like that the
bitcoin
uh bull market's been going on so long
when it goes down it'll really go down
no
you think not nope i think a bitcoin uh
it'll have it has its periods um it it
hits 20k a few years ago and then
dropped down to like seven and everyone
was like no
and people some people mortgaged their
homes and they were panicking
and that was a huge mistake because if
they had just held onto the
onto the bitcoin it would be 60. there
were people who
bought in at 20 000 and when it tanked
panicked and sold
thinking i've lost everything oh yeah of
course but my point is like as
the market expands as more people become
participants in it
the uh the panics grow more severe
because there are more people panicking
more people selling
when what's gonna happen is so recently
i think it dipped down to like 47
in the past couple of weeks and then a
bunch of institutional investors
immediately were like yes
and they bought it all up for discounts
knowing that it's gonna go up
i think a bitcoin will reach a bitcoin
will reach a million dollars
and probably more than that but i think
a million at some point and i think
particularly soon
for two reasons the buying power of the
dollar is dropping dramatically
and the investment into bitcoin
infrastructure is going up dramatically
so that means the value of a theorem in
bitcoin
they're literally gaining value as more
people want them the demand is high
but also corn is up 44
so if you're holding a dollar you can
only buy half as much corn
you're holding a bitcoin you can buy
even more corn
so bitcoin's going to go up it's
deflationary it is a funded amount
coins are lost every day demand is
increasing the price can only go up and
you know what
a one with eight decimal points
one bitcoin and then you put a period
and then you do eight zeros
you know what happened if you got rid of
that decimal point put commas
you'd get one million point zero zero i
think bitcoin had a million dollars
so that's just my opinion i'm not
telling anybody to do anything but i'll
tell you this
um you do what you think is right you
talk to your financial advisor
i'm gonna buy crypto i'm also gonna buy
i i you know you know what i invest in
things i can use because i'll tell you
one thing
an investment into a cryptocurrency or
gold or silver or anything like that
is an investment predicated upon your
belief
the system will not collapse the dollar
may lose value
inflation may happen but you do believe
you'll still be able to trade within the
system
if you're actually worried about the
apocalypse then you need to invest in
like a well
water tanks uh store 30-year bins of
beans
bunker yeah bunker i'll tell you if you
imagine going you know the apocalypse
and you're like
please sir i need water i've got a
bitcoin he's going to be like i don't
care how many bitcoin you got
like water is life someone's gonna walk
up and be like yo i've got
a sandwich and they're gonna be like
let's let's divide and trade the
sandwich because food is more important
yeah there are companies that uh sell
luxury bunkers to people
here in america oh yeah yeah there's
like there's old converted silos oh yeah
they're beautiful yeah i watched i think
i was watching a mr beast episode
you ever watched mr beast where i think
it was mr beast
he goes to one of these bunker silos
it's it's creepy stuff
but they're like they're like five foot
concrete reinforced
because they were meant for you know
missiles that wouldn't be blown up if
they were
you know missile striked or whatever and
there's like there was a beach room
where the walls are painted
then they have like bedrooms with tvs
for windows
so you can see out outside
yeah that's cool stuff yeah some people
went into like uh their bunkers their
luxury bunkers when kobet started they
thought the apocalypse was here
wow yeah what other good things to get
if you're expecting that like
solar i would think like just some sort
of like renewable energy electricity
source and like a ham radio or something
some way to generate electricity yeah i
know that we don't rely on fossil fuels
like solar yesterday we were talking
about but
it's not really feasible it's like it's
like a society's functioning electricity
source not really a little bit solar
yeah but if if all of a sudden we
couldn't pay our electric bill because
u.s dollars were
so deflated in value that no that
wouldn't even get them anymore
that wouldn't happen right so the issue
is there's
the value of the currency will work to a
certain degree within the country it
won't work for for
imports so if your country is dependent
upon importing certain goods
then you're in serious trouble but trade
between two individuals within the
country
is probably going to be fine so the
issue
for a place like venezuela is that
they're dependent on on a bunch of
external corporations like
for flight for travel for transport and
it's increasingly coming true for a lot
of countries that you're dependent upon
other countries
goods and services so that being said
so long as you don't have a command
economy like venezuela your farms will
probably still produce
and they'll have to adjust prices for
the things you know that they that they
need to produce the stuff
it could make it so that you have to
work harder to get food for sure
but you'll still be able to get
electricity lumber
are we importing a bunch of lumber is
that why we went upstairs i do think we
import lumber
i do but uh uh i think we import a lot
of it actually i'm not entirely sure you
can use fly shortages
i think you can use i don't know if it's
an exact uh duplication of wood like
you're not getting exactly what you get
out of wood with him but
hemp fiber you can kind of constitute
for
wood i've heard and it grows fast hemp
does
well the housing market is blowing up
right now so i mean that might be why
they're
what do you mean like prices are
skyrocketing yeah yeah that's inflation
yeah and people are building houses
people are building houses yep
well yeah and and here's the other
thing's going to happen because the cost
of lumber and steel is so high
the cost to build a house is going to go
up dramatically which is going to drive
the price of everyone else's houses way
up
now here's the crazy thing sounds like
an acid bubble to me yeah we'll check
this out
let's say you buy a house for 200 000
and you bought it you know five years
ago
now the us dollar is inflating like
crazy you still owe two hundred thousand
dollars
if the buying power of that dollar is
dramatically reduced
that means you owe less labor on your
loan
and then your house is going to
skyrocket in value because of inflation
so when you hear these people say don't
worry inflation's a good thing
i guess you know for americans because
we basically control the petrol dollar
might actually be now your savings will
be completely decimated right
so that's bad your asset value through
the roof
yup so hard assets will retain their
value
and what will happen is i'll put it this
way even if i owe you a dollar
right now a dollar can buy a candy bar
i say that basically i owe the amount of
labor to produce one candy bar to ian
i'm going to wait a year now a dollar
can't buy a candy bar anymore
it can only buy a quarter of a candy bar
i owe you less physical goods are they
gonna are they gonna enforce
like yeah we know you said you were
gonna owe a hundred grand but that
underground's worth 400 grand so you owe
us 400. nope they can't do that you
can't do that i mean i guess if somebody
has like a fixed variable loan they can
like drive the variable rate up for some
reason or whatever but i don't know how
that works so
but uh yeah if you owe
a hundred thousand dollars on your house
and then the currency in flights and
then when i think within a year
it hyperinflates imagine people are
shoveling money into the street
because it's worthless you go to your
bank and you're like uh here's the money
i owe you and you just shovel it off
from the ground and throw it at them
so the system can't work that way people
will take out loans to buy assets and
then when the asset triples in price
they'll sell off half of it pay back the
loan with a profit
take out it's rinse repeat ponzi scheme
what they what what uh i can't remember
which outlet was an investor out that
said the good news for inflation is it
means that your wages are going to start
skyrocketing as well
and i'm like it's funny you think that's
good news it's good news for people with
no savings
you got nothing to worry about you got
no savings nothing's gonna collapse on
you
so it is technically technically a good
thing
now for a lot of people who are like
middle class who have a decent savings
no real hard assets it's pretty bad for
you
so you don't want to be holding well i'm
not going to give anyone advice on what
you should do but i'll say i would not
want to be holding us dollars
which is kind of a problem because you
know you use it for everyday
interactions
but for poor people they're probably not
going to notice
they're going to be like the prices are
going up they're going to go to their
job i need a raise the business is going
to have to do it
then you know they work at walmart then
walmart's going to have to increase the
cost of goods across the board to pay
higher salaries
or to pay higher hourly wages and then
the people who have a loan on their car
are going to be
like wow when i took this loan out for
ten thousand dollars i was making 10
bucks an hour
six months later i'm making 20 bucks an
hour my loan was basically cut in half
in terms of the amount of work i have to
do to pay it off
so win for certain people i guess and
then everyone else around the world will
be forced to contend with our
hyperinflation because we're america
we'll blow them up so banks that would
put a lot of burden on the banks that
send out the loans so would you expect
that banks will stop giving out loans
say that one more time if the if if the
burden then would fall on the banks that
loaned you 50 000 that's not only worth
25 when you pay it back
that's their problem does that mean that
they're going to stop handing out loans
because of that potential risk is that
normally it happens before uh
if there's hyperinflation yeah maybe
maybe another question this gets into us
how long will america be able to just go
around the world blowing up small
countries without any serious opposition
china is rising very very quickly yep
not long i don't think not long yeah i
actually tend to be
a uh 15 maybe someone you mean seven
maybe 2020 is when they're expecting
china to overtake the us's economy
we know about thucydides trap so cool
like i don't know what were you going to
say alan uh i
i think china is so it can be a little
bit overrated if you look at history
rising powers often don't beat the
declining power because the declining
power tends to have
more allies and more diplomatic clout
that it's built up over many years of
being the dominant power
this is exactly what happened with uh
britain and germany germany was
on course to overtake britain its
industrial capacity before world war one
but britain won because it had more
allies
had an empire been around for longer had
all that dip all of those diplomatic
resources
that it turned into these alliances and
it was able to beat germany
through coalith through a coalition uh
you look at china
china is sort of on its own because
america will have japan taiwan
uh maybe south korea south korea might
not want to get involved because you
know it's much more vulnerable than say
japan
by the ocean but america will have a lot
more if it came to like a confrontation
with china america would have a lot more
allies and what allies were trying to
really have
russia it comes down to russia again the
great wild card like if hitler hadn't
invaded russia he would have won the war
it seemingly at least that the math kind
of shows that well if he didn't hesitate
there was that famous battle whatever
where he that his what i can remember
because that's what happened stalingrad
no no no moscow moscow they were already
right they were like a hundred people
general inside moscow and then right had
divert to stalingrad something like that
they they hesitated allowing russia to
uh to generate reinforcements
essentially yes they could have taken
moscow but they decided to go elsewhere
man well hubris i guess
he thought he could do what napoleon
couldn't but if russia gets involved
then you could potentially start a whole
domino effect where europe gets involved
as well and then you have like a genuine
world war in your hands
right yeah so invest in uh a bunker i
guess
yeah there's in love with your friends
and family we had a guy on from a place
called fortitude ranch
and they called in their members
the like in october just before the
election saying like the potential for
volatility is higher than normal
i don't think they really expected the
world to end but they put out a call
like
a decent you know a decently high single
digit percentage of something bad
happening
you know genuine fear that
yeah something look this instability is
not going to go away you know why
i mean you make a good point about the
media being the problem brian stelter
is is a dangerous guy um i think you
know cuomo is probably worse
but he is because he's trying to make
sure that everyone stays agitated
anxious and and suffering from anxiety
attacks all the time
like january 6 is over dude it's not
happening anymore
it happened it's gone away but he wants
to make sure these people
only stare at this and these hearings
and people are just shaking terrified of
the far right
meanwhile there actually is a problem of
far leftists going around rioting
protesting burning down buildings
and they ignore that so he's keeping
people distracted from the real problems
while keeping them
in in a consistent panic attack state
over something that happened four months
ago
he he looks like the joker kind of his
mouth do you guys ever notice that
the ends of his mouth go up like the
joker's smile like really brian's delta
they're still okay
hey don't compliment the guys i don't
want to joke with that joker's cool i
don't like even making fun of joker's
base
dude joker's lit no no joker was a bad
guy um
i don't want to make making fun of
people for their appearances ever but
i've noticed that smile
is that like a hysterical like not not a
happy smile but like a
psychotic like what is he smiling about
if he's so afraid
i don't get it i don't know let's go to
super chats
my friends if you haven't already please
smash that like button
and comment because it helps the show
and uh we appreciate it
you can also go to timecast.com become a
member because we're gonna have an
exclusive members only segment coming up
after the show around 11 pm we put it up
every day we have a huge library of
content some of your favorite people
talking about just fun and crazy stuff
and some serious stuff as well but don't
forget to like
share and subscribe to this channel
let's read we got austin norton
he says ethereum is now above 3500
usd a new all-time high eth to the moon
i wonder if it's because ethereum people
are discovering it
or if it's because the dollar is garbage
yeah maybe a little bit of both
does the chat think the joke was based
or not based
type one for best all right let's see we
got here christian
jim gocheon says tim conservatives
protest with their wallets
coke goes woke they make it go broke the
bottom line changes
companies change tune money talks bs
walks corporate profit owns the us
government
i i mean i i hear that but i don't think
conservatives are organized enough to
actually stage effective
boycotts however there's rumors about
like gina karana coming back coming back
to disney plus so maybe and the coke
thing for sure
i think that stuff will happen long-term
alternative companies for all sorts of
things
i think we should start building the
infrastructure kenny jackson says
sn uh one five stuck its landing i saw
that that's crazy
starship the elon musk started what
happened it landed it did it i
altitude test came back down and landed
nice that's crazy because
that's massive brought some dough coin
back from the moon
mediocre fisherman says would you rather
have 100 dogs of any kind or 100 cats
that's a tough call um it's tough
the cats i would have to worry about so
it depends on what i need them for or
what
they're doing if i'm like trying to
conquer a small
village the dogs for sure if i'm just
chilling
and minding my own business the cats
heck yeah they just could go do their
thing and
whatever the question said have what
were you gonna say i'll take the cats
cats can look after themselves
dogs require constant attention yeah cat
because if you had to keep them inside
the cat pee would be better than the dog
poop
but you can train dogs to attack your
enemies so you know in the apocalypse
scenario you'd want the dogs
yeah omg puppies says democrats expand
federal federal power permanent
one-party rule
long march through the institutions gop
we will lower your taxes
which is meaningless in the long run
our dubu says o r lag uh oregon
legislation
passed egregious anti-gun sb554 today
with the help of sellout rhinos uh now
the
now to fear brown's desk to sign voting
collapsitarian from here on out
establishment can win the slow game
let's see how fast they can dance not
enough people are willing to
uh uh to challenge the system they're
still
defending cops like like i mentioned a
cop walks into a woman's
shop which is closed and tells her to
stop posting to facebook that she's
selling things
she would have been allowed to do that
from her house it was just because she
was working out of the business they had
i
i i don't think it matters i think it's
irrelevant the fact is her business was
closed
because they said you're not allowed to
be open we're shut down and so she's
like i'll post a video on facebook and
the cops showed up and said you gotta
you gotta stop doing this because we're
talking about my stores closed
and they're like no you're on facebook
and then people are like back to blue
baby
i love it when the cops came and shut
down attila's gym and we even had the
dude from a telesand
and they apologized to the cops no no i
don't get mad at them they're just doing
their jobs i'm like what are you talking
about
just doing it what they're going to look
back at us like barbarians
in 500 600 years they're gonna look back
like this is like the year 300 a.d and
we're like savages
why because this is so pedantic to use
this
is so ridiculous that we're still
trying to climb on top of each other for
money
it's it's hideous it's not the way
societies or living organisms are meant
to function
i mean if free-thinking people
lose and the authoritarian regime takes
over
you know i want to make sure everyone
understands something they say every
time communism has been tried it's
failed
you know that every time communism but
it's not real communism
well it's never real communist but the
next time communism is tried
it will win it will it will work you
know why
because it's never been tried because no
because of surveillance state
the one thing that they didn't have was
supreme control they can
stop the thought before it happens how
could any citizen organize
of china organize against china unless
of course
they can't maintain a basic standard of
goods
if there is if there is a lack of access
to food which is why a lot of the
soviets
the communist states failed but i think
the ability to manipulate and
propagandize at a level never seen
before
and the ability to track down and remove
dissidents immediately
we'll make sure the next communist
regime functions within or or can't be
toppled
functionally imagine if they were like
reading your brain impulses with neural
net and like
this guy has signs that he's going to
start thinking bad thoughts in three
months we got to get to them pre-crime
bro
free crime oh yeah minority report
the movie unqualified studio says hey
tim we took your comments about creating
culture to heart and launched a brand
based off of that mission
we'd love it if you check us out right
on we will take a look
jack o'neal says tim why are you
sleeping on stargate sg1
the tv show was amazing but the movie
was bad i'll take a look at the show
sg1 does come on after sliders
periodically on comet i think
is that macgyver richard dean anderson
was he in that or was he i don't know
i've not seen sg1
one of them was in the movie
sonny james says do people really think
zuck and gates are geniuses no the
federal government built those companies
up in exchange for backdoor access
look no further than the feds using fb
and instagram to track down capital
rioters
that's your user agreement folks you
know i love
there's a meme where it's like joe rogan
makes comment about vaccine
joe rogan who's not a doctor makes you
know says you know young people
shouldn't take the vaccine
and then the next one next to it is bill
gates five things bill gates wants you
to know about the vaccine
dr bill gates md yeah dr bill gates it
was the same paper
that put those articles out too same uh
fauci is a tv doctor people need to
realize this he's not practicing
he's not practicing he's a tv doctor
okay
talk to your doctor to find out what's
right for you
it's remarkable that you have people on
one side being like dr fauci action
figures there's like a dr fauci pizza
someone posted this where it's like it's
a face on a pizza with onions and olives
and i'm like these people are insane
and then i'm just like dude i don't care
if you're joe rogan
md dr oz dr drew dr phil or dr fauci
i'm not gonna go to the tv to figure out
what i should be doing with my health
i'm gonna i'm gonna call a doctor and
guess what there's something called a
second opinion yeah go call a million
doctors this is your life well not even
a million i mean a couple
it's normal like i i had to get you know
a dental thing done a few years ago and
i called the net it's like what do you
think who will do this
let me call another dentist we'll do
this i'm like okay i got a second
opinion
great it's a normal thing breakthrough
you always gotta keep your eyes open
yet why is it so hard for people to say
don't listen to tv doctors
well honestly do you have a reason
because i think people are
are like heard we're like hurt animals
in a way 90 90
of us are just wired to follow the crowd
yeah why do they make people into cult
figures so easily
[Music]
the wall murals of everyone so many war
murals our government
is a cult it's centered around one human
and we well i get to pick who we want to
call
you're talking about just confidence in
a system but the way we built it is all
around one
individual like why do we worship the
individual like that why are people who
just want to tune out and let that guy
lead us to victory
we don't well a lot of i don't a lot of
people do
i think they're listening to the tv i i
think they
trust cuomo on uh
andrew cuomo more than just the
president of the of the united states
people in california were wearing shirts
saying like
what what what did it say it was like
single taken dating cuomo in my mind or
something
like these shirts yeah they're calling
themselves cuomosexuals
no joke yeah that that's that's crazy
and that wasn't the president that's
just people who are nuts
i know so some countries are led by
actual strongmen or alleged strongman uh
some
sometimes saner than america you
wouldn't catch drag queen story hour
happening in russia
yeah no that's that that'd be that's
where the kids were twerking
no no no no not where the kids people
were working for kids or something yeah
yeah but there have been a bunch of
instances where kids are brought on
stage to do
shows for adults image jpeg says
bitcoin cash hit 14.80 today a world
currency isn't going to be dogged should
it either be bitcoin cash or monero or
both
yeah so there was a bitcoin forked
from bitcoin to bitcoin cash and that
means that if you had bitcoin at the
time
you had the equal amounts of bitcoin
cash i had that yeah and then bitcoin
cash
like i think it hit like 10 or 20 grand
or some ridiculous number and then
dropped way down to like 300
because people didn't know which one was
gonna win out they're like what which
one is going to be the dominant
because bitcoin cash is supposed to be
low fees and fast transactions
like cash and bitcoin had become
basically gold
so i think you know you get both you get
free money
all right talbot link says wikipedia
totally defamed tim
said he had a zeppelin everyone knows
that graphene rocket blimps are where
it's at best way to the moon
we're actually working on a zeppelin
project rocket blimps huh
yeah rocket blimp how would that work i
don't know we are working on a zeppelin
um yeah actually it's just a matter of
some paperwork at this point that's
right
and then we're gonna film it for the
vlog over at cass castle and we're going
to have the zeppelin project with
cameras on it and we're going to go film
and
and then it will be real it's a big zap
one too yeah i was like 20
24 18 and a half i think big old
zeppelin
all right let's see is there something
about doge what do we got going on here
curtis says everyone loves crypto but if
it keeps going like it is hardwell
hardware will rise to insane levels my
30 80 mine's 15
a day right now imagine if eta hits 20k
home computing will be a thing of the
past
we were talking about running last night
yeah but people don't realize it's
expensive because you use a lot of
electricity
and people were saying it's not the
future of uh crypto creation yeah mining
so
yeah it's archaic it was like have your
computer work hard to solve an equation
so that there's
it was like creating arbitrary work to
make a digital asset work there's other
ways to to do it
yes proof of stake right that doesn't
require mining at all yeah
i'm still do you can you explain what
that is uh no okay kind of out of my
head maybe tomorrow we'll talk about it
but you but
that that's a reference to holding
crypto and then you you get a percentage
generated
yeah yeah yeah so ethereum is i think
it's what ability of 32
ethereum you stake it and then as a
holder as the theorem is generated you
get a percentage increase right yeah
okay now it's ringing about you can do
this with other cryptos as well
you can stake a certain amount of
ethereum or whatever currency and that
proof of stake will as long as you keep
it there it's going to generate more
it's like interest in a bank account so
your ownership of the asset
increases the value or the of the assets
increases the amount yeah it's like
having a bank account
it's like having your money in uh wealth
management or whatever with an
interest rate increase eric miller says
trump should run
for congress he will have to be unbanned
from social media and they don't have
term limits but after trump maybe they
will
i don't know about that that's looking
they'll still keep him banned they
didn't unban laura loomer
sonny james says china holds our debt
when there's no gold in fort knox
land and resources become collateral
don't people realize printing money
ain't free
you'll own nothing and have no privacy
yuri besmanov did say the elites won't
get off but jack made what is it
jack ma oh jack mod okay i see what i
see what he's saying
oh and who disappeared basically jack ma
i think he did a video
chat listen a couple weeks ago if they
can take away your memory
if they can erase the culture of freedom
and classical liberalism and things like
that
then people will be happy with no
privacy if they don't know any better
you know we got we got we got chickens
outside right their whole lives
has just been in this one little box
they know nothing of the outside world
and it's and it's troubles and
they're either happy or sad based on
whether or not i throw a meal worm at
them
if they understood you know freedom i
mean actually
so bucko is an outside cat now and he
did not know the joys of the of the real
world because he was never allowed
outside
just discovered it out of plato's cave
and yeah exactly
exactly and so i'm wondering like did we
curse him with the knowledge of freedom
no because no no the first the first
week he's like running around like crazy
changing butterflies
now he just sits on the porch and he
just you know sits there
we got back today and he was in the
clubhouse out back and he went ah i came
running
he's probably peeing in there such a
yeah i was thinking that too jerk
all right oompa loompa says sec chairman
gensler
is going before congress to expose
adele's unfair trading practices
tomorrow bring your popcorn
this could be the catalyst that
initiates a second wave of short
squeezes against hedge funds
with massive short positions so is that
game stop
uh to the moon is that what's gonna
happen perhaps
all right where are we at here rebel
phoenix says let's fight cancel culture
and start buying everything that might
get cancelled because capitalism is the
perfect solution to the problem
nobody will cancel anything when they
are making millions
gotta organize that's the issue the left
has so
many organizations that tell people what
to do and they just do it
so you get a company will be like it'll
send out a mass email to
a million people saying hey everybody
email coke and tell them they're racist
and they will and then coke gets hit by
a million emails and they go we better
do something about this
they'll make it even easier they'll have
like click this button and it'll open a
form letter to them for them with all
the stuff texted there for them and then
you know email membership guy or
whatever at coke
he's like we have 53 000 emails in the
past hour
what do we do it's like what are they
about they're all mad about how we said
you know we supported georgia oh and
we're gonna put out a statement right
now and denounce it
yeah also this whole you know a business
will follow profit thing i mean
underestimates how zealously the
corporate elites actually believe this
stuff
gillette lost you know an insane amount
of money with their work staff and the
ceo still said well
you know we we still stand by our our
work values
alan rogers says ian did you just hear
about smedley butler
or do you honestly think it's 1970 1917
and there's more money exchanging hands
between the government and defense
contractors in the government and media
handyman tn says ian you're so close
they're not selling bullets to selling
airplanes
scott horton explains in great detail on
his youtube channel in small
three-minute-ish videos it's fantastic
thank you i'm looking up smedley butler
right now i've never heard of him before
yeah the banker plot
old gimlet eye yeah the old banker plot
blast cap badger says iraq afghanistan
vet here
in iraq we found nuclear processing and
waste facilities with tons of stuff in
them
other government agencies came in after
we secured it have not heard a word
about it since
something that alarms me to this day
creepy
eli m says can we have a ian lives
matter shirt
i guess well definitely
woods says tim tex and rebel thanks for
working out login issues on timcast.com
sent digital art in last email to member
support
same name will send framed print just
let me know where to send it in
a response uh isn't the po box on the
website yeah
under contact i think yep yeah there you
go yeah so apologies to everybody
um as i've stated before for the
timcast.com website
we did not expect it to grow as quickly
as it did and it's not
easy to just snap our fingers and have
the website that can handle the amount
of traffic and the amount of members and
everything so we've had we've had
problems but we're working on it uh
people have canceled and you know i
apologize
if you know you felt the need to cancel
because something wasn't working
but i get it if you can't get access it
makes no sense to be giving anybody any
money so
i apologize but we're a few weeks out
from a complete
again re-upgrade new everything and
again
we're gonna be adding a newsroom so
we're gonna have articles we're gonna
have
more content and you can send to
jobscass.com right now if you are a
video producer documentary producer
and you want to produce some short
documentaries between 10 and 20 minutes
for us
because we are taking pictures and we're
going to be commissioning some of these
out to uh to
on on a contract basis and there are
some ideas i have that we we need
somebody right now you send me an email
right now
we'll we'll look at it if you're if
you're sen you know send us
examples of your work and if they're
good you could be on a plane tomorrow
well assuming the plane lets you on and
you're wearing a mask but you get the
point
there are some stories and we're ready
to pull the trigger on
all right trash panda says ian i know
you mean well but not everything can be
solved by technology
the problem is the far left is waging
war against classical liberalism
and we will not win until we treat them
as the enemies they are
i know you're right and i do talk a lot
especially on this show because it's
like a talk show but
and i know that the solutions aren't
simple man they're just not otherwise we
would probably already figure them out
already
adam thm says tim how can we change
people's minds
who we can show them the news articles
and proof they're wrong and they still
look in our faces and say so what
yeah that's uh really difficult i
honestly don't know there was a
political the study in political
psychology like 10 or so years back i
think it was brendan nyhan who did it
uh the more you show partisans
information that contradicts their
beliefs
the stronger those beliefs grow right
yeah because you're an enemy
so uh you have to approach them as an
ally
the first thing you need to have is a
rapport and so you need to be agreeing
with them
and then i used to there's an old
technique in
um you know like sales and it's
to this i'll put this away the big ask
you're familiar with the big ask
uh it's where you say like hey i'll sell
you this box a kleenex for a hundred
dollars
and then you're gonna be like that's
insane 100 okay but i'll give you half
off 50
bucks so you walked it back and i'm like
oh i'm getting a deal
that's that that's part of a similar
concept called rapport extreme turn
where you approach someone who has a
political belief as their ally
agree with them even if you don't agree
they say like i'm a big fan of this
politician you say me too oh man high
five
then you present to them in extreme a
big ask something they can't agree with
in terms of politics
i'm i'm grateful to the to the you know
bolstering of soldiers in the middle
east
because it's about time the u.s shows
the world what imperialism really means
and then when they say i disagree with
you
you say well maybe you're not as big a
supporter of you know politician as i am
but i can still respect it you agree
with them
and then you've given them the position
where they've disagreed with the
politician
not you you didn't approach them as an
enemy you didn't tell them they were
wrong and stupid
you said i like politician too because
he did act so when they say i don't like
xa well okay well then
agree to disagree you'd have to like him
as much as i do but i like him
now in their mind they've said i
disagree you see how that works
i'm not a big fan of that stuff i used
to do sales i didn't like it
i like just saying it and people don't
get it but i guess the problem is
there are people who understand the
human mind and how social engineering
works edward bernays
nell exploited every step of the way to
gain power and they are and the people
who are like i don't want to play these
games well
then we lose i guess but i don't know so
you do you know gotta be subversive
kind that's subversive you don't gotta
be but that's one tactic
kurt crosby says critical theory is like
pouring ketchup on a fruit salad great
show guys jacob donaldworth says hey tim
if you want a break from all the serious
stuff check out my book
an officer and a man on amazon tons of
funny stories about being an officer in
the usmc
i'm a huge fan of the show keep doing
great things thank you so much
appreciate it if you guys are huge fans
of the show
you can just share it on facebook or
social media just take the link and
we should we should probably you know
get make an easy way for people to just
do that that's
that's really the way to grow the show
and then
i don't know how you sometimes just
can't convince people it goes
shawn anderson says card cardano ada
crypto is doing cool stuff in ethiopia
people need to buy real projects not
garbage like dogecoin or eth classic
well i think eth is valuable a lot of
companies use it
seth says whoever convinced the american
people that politics is his complex
spectrum with dozens of labels
has got this country under their thumb
politics is power nothing more it's
really that simple
yeah it doesn't matter what party line
they write down on paper
oh man a porn crypto
yes and it's skyrocketing in value of
course 21st century politics
tom m says zimbabwe had hyperinflation
where a trash bag of money got you a
soda or it was burned for warmth
kept printing out bigger bills and
pushing more money to the economy to
keep up
had one million dollar bills money
printer go gur
yeah i think i saw that once i was at a
restaurant and they had like a million
dollar bill or something from zimbabwe
and it was just like just ridiculous
amount of zeros i'm like wow
but why would anyone even it makes no
sense why would you use it
it's not worth anything just meaningless
why would i trade with it
alex on earth says look dot
updigitaldollarproject.org forward slash
publications for the latest in the
future of digital currency in the usa
we'll check it out thank you alan jin
says a lingen be more worried about the
money sharing services between the banks
zell and its parent company they are
tied into most of the major banks they
are using bad contracts to lock out
people from it
and taking their info creepy
daniel welch says did you see a g bar is
under scrutiny for memo
so if you try to stop a baseless witch
hunt it's obstruction
nothing more than a legal kafka trap yep
that's the power they have there you go
nicholas doyle says at uh to to us the
bitcoin cycles are a result of the four
year payout halving having cycle causing
a run because low supply
people are too aware too aware to repeat
it now so
basically what happens is the halving
right yeah so people know when there's
going to be a strain
and so the miners hold it until the
strain hits and then they can sell at
you know they can make a bigger profit
but now that people are aware of it
the coin starting to stabilize nobody
wants to sell they want to hold
and it makes sense but i guess the issue
is
who cares if you're holding bitcoin
nobody wants to trade it
i mean i guess people do people you can
buy it the price slowly goes up because
people do buy it
but then if the price is gonna keep
going up why would i sell it i guess
i guess if you have to yeah if you need
an asset or something yeah
i mean i guess if all of my if all of my
money and all of my assets were bitcoin
i'd be trading some out to buy stuff
with you know
jonathan dugger says tim lumber is
skyrocketing because loggers are doing
the same thing as diamond miners they're
holding on to it to spike the prices oh
my gosh
wow xrunner says there's a production
side of this
what happens when producers stop working
farmers in venezuela quitting was one
variable in their demise
interesting unknown says a guy at work
made 30
000 30k on doge with a 6k initial
investment
paid off his wife's student loans in his
vehicle we make 35k a year 40-hour
workweek
wow the gift of doge man
oh just jumped on me don't jump on me
what are you doing here we go manuel
delgado says the incan from kansas
treat a man as he is and he will remain
as he is treat a man as he could be and
he'll become what he should be
america's worst day is still better than
any day in the rest of the world
be the true change put up or shut up
mentality
diego salazar says your democrats are
our
parents all social justice and equality
while filling their pockets
funny thing is that perrin was a nazi
that used the young left to return to
power in 72
greets from argentina second place in
the inflation ranking perron
perron is how you say it yeah yeah yeah
that was eva peron's husband what was
his name
paren parent i'm allowed to not know how
to pronounce words
i demand people say things the way i do
jason dunn says fun fact there's an
island in greece with what with hundreds
of cats
if you can apply to care for six months
over the summer
i applied years ago because i wanted to
get away but i didn't get in it's pretty
awesome
that's great uh japan has a cat island
too oh yes yeah
where's the rabbit island there's that
too wow oh is it wait yeah japan is
rabbit island i think so yeah is that
what i'm thinking of
i thought they had canada then there's
pig island
there's snake island too do you see the
island of the dead yeah snake island
but you're hanging bodies a little
different
creepy never fidella says
hogue finance is what doge should have
been from the beginning large supply
with deflationary tokenomics
there's a two percent tax in which one
percent of the transaction is deleted
forever
and the other one percent is distributed
between the holders
what's interesting yeah
op says what's a good place to buy
crypto i don't want to buy from a place
like robin hood
i don't know coinbase gemini block 5 is
pretty good
takes a while though don't you want to
support the winklevia
absolutely the winklevoss twins the
winkle i like to get to know those guys
coinbase is good on the sjw question
they ban political activism in the
workplace
people wow hey good for them
dj delev says how many more times will
tim say
spineless i guess at least one more
thanks to the super chat the last man
1084 says check out the book color
communism
and common sense by manning johnson the
book talks about communist infiltration
in the u.s
very interesting the jobless coders says
i live 50 yards from the church of
a pastor who yelled at the cops he has
been targeted for months by police
arrested for feeding the homeless
and i don't understand how at this point
conservatives are still supporting the
cops i don't get it
i guess you gotta is that supporting the
individual cop
or the institution of policing i don't
know i feel
my personal opinion is that uh many
people are just scared to speak out of
line with what their tribe says so i
look at cops arresting small business
owners
arresting a church a pastor for opening
their church
shutting down churches and synagogues i
i see the cops in new york holding up
cameras to the windows of jewish schools
to make sure the little jewish children
can't be learning
and padlocking gates shut and i'm like
at the time we're gonna have a
discussion about this we should have
some reforms
but i think we need police even when
we're seeing these bad things
and then they start you know when they
start arresting more and more
conservatives and releasing antifa
not arresting more even when they do the
ds caught him list i'm like you guys
how could you support i understand you
want to be nice to these cops don't want
to blame them for the fact that da's are
cutting antifa loose
but why would you prop up a system in
which conservatives will be funneled off
into the prison system
and the far left will be shuffled off
free of you know
no charges free to go oh it's
complicated right because you know the
left is pushing against the kind of
policing that people want policing in
their neighborhood stopping actual crime
stop and search
things that actually lowered crime but
at the same time the left's putting the
police you know arrest people
throw people in jail for trespassing and
protest and they're doing all of it yeah
so the cops the cops aren't going to the
neighborhoods to stop crime anymore
but they're still going and arresting
small business owners still to this day
in the minneapolis area a woman she was
uh
uh opened her wine and coffee bar she
got arrested
how how could she make it how could she
take it this far
that's creepy yeah so at this point i'm
just like i don't i don't know what
y'all are doing because
sooner or later if this system persists
it is it is a simple algorithm
conservatives and moderates are more
likely to go to jail and get locked up
and the left is going to be released and
let go over a long enough period of time
conservatives and moderates many who
become felons for some of these charges
won't be able to vote
or they'll be in jail and the far left
will romp up
around smashing windows and burning
things down and the cops are the ones
enforcing this stuff
no institution is on your side i want to
be like crack down on the mob
on the on the violence but like i don't
want to be this crazy authoritarian is
it crazy
to say that to be like national guard
activate protect the country
the way to understand it is left-wing
speak left-wing violence is speech and
conservative speech is violence
that's right that's how they understand
the world whoa
wicked lis says constitutional carry has
passed in texas
on way to mayor who said we'll sign you
mean governor
constitutional carry in texas man if
texas passes this law i'll be really
excited i might move there
that'd be great it's a promising law
yeah
all right let's see we'll do a couple
more super chats what do we got here
maya e says please have gothics andy no
and carol swain as guests love your show
the challenge uh for andy well i i don't
know i
andy's not in the u.s anymore right i
heard he was overseas oh yeah okay
yeah so i'd love to have gothics though
yeah um
we're an in studio show man
tofu pancho says that communism line
always sounds dirty to me
come on babe just give it a shot you
just don't like it because no one has
done it right before
yeah that's right
okay alessio de monte
says i think this is the first time ian
wants to explode but can't because the
channel will be cancelled
it's like the third or fourth time yeah
yeah it's definitely one of them though
track media only says similar as you
raise minimum wage
after time uh no one is making more
because money is worthless as things
cost more in response
all you do is make some poorer and
others with expense
hard asset expensive hard assets richer
yeah you try explaining some of these
leftists they don't quite understand it
like money is essentially meaningless
like a us dollar doesn't get you
something it's just at a certain point
in time it represents a certain amount
of
value so you do labor you get a certain
amount
in exchange for your labor and then you
can buy a certain amount of things with
that labor but over time your labor
becomes worth less and less and less
money is a trade medium that people use
it could literally be anything it could
be seashells
the idea is scarcity so it's hard to
replicate so us money is printed by the
government it's hard to make
you can't it's illegal to counterfeit
and it's hard to counterfeit so you know
that you have a secure
you know trade medium the problem is the
government inflates the currency so it
loses value over time
anyway my friends you must go to
timkes.com and become members because we
have an exclusive members only segment
coming up in about an hour
you can follow us on this show on
facebook at facebook.comcast.irl where
where you can like the page
and then share our clips to help spread
the good word is that that is timcast
irl
and then eventually people will come to
teamcast.com we're going to be doing a
whole bunch more stuff like i said
we're going to be doing some mini docs
right away
um and they'll be up for members only on
the site once we start producing them so
we need some
applications some pitches for people who
either have story ideas
you got to send examples of your work
and if it's good you could be on a plane
tomorrow
so uh make sure you do that you can also
follow us on instagram at tim cast irl
and you can follow me at tim cast
you can check out my other channels
youtube.comcast and youtube.comcastnews
this show is live monday through friday
at 8pm so make sure you
smash the like button subscribe hit the
notification bell alum
you got stuff to promote uh if you want
to learn more about the tyranny of the
tech giants and what they're doing you
can find my book by searching for
deleted
big tanks battle to erase the trump
movement and steal the election and for
the latest in all tech news go to
breitbart news
uh you can also follow my work at
iancrossland.net you can get in touch
with me via a lot of social networks at
ian crossland so i'm really really
thankful thanks for coming through that
was awesome
yeah so i looked up that quote about uh
them lying it goes like this and it's
not from
soldier knitting oh it's not oh my god
so it's like apparently really often
misquoted it says the rules are simple
they lie to us we know they're lying
they know we know they
they're lying but they keep lying to us
and we keep pretending to believe them
and it's from an author and artist named
elena gorkova who lived during the
soviet union
interesting anyway you can follow me at
sarah patchell it's on twitter if you so
desire
we will see you all at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out
bye guys
you